bonjour à tous suite ce matin du projet
de loi sur la réforme des retraites et
début d'une semaine décisive au
programme d'aujourd'hui l'article 6 et
le report de la retraite à taupelin de
65 à 67 ans c'est l'une des deux mesures
phares du texte après l'adoption
vendredi soir du report de l'âge légal
de départ à la retraite de 60 à 62 ans
alors que le Sénat mène cette réforme
tambourbattant les syndicats restent
mobilisés une journée de manifestation
et de grève est prévue demain et une
autre samedi et par ailleurs dans
plusieurs secteurs notamment les
transports ou encore l'énergie un
préavis de grève reconductible a été
déposé c'est dire si le mouvement peut
se durcir tout de suite direction
l'hémicycle pour l'examen du texte et à
M45 on fait le point avec Pierre-Henri
gergon semaine qui viennent nous avons
donc intérêt autant que devoir de
permettre aux femmes d'être ces piliers
non seulement de la vie familiale mais à
partir de la vie familiale ces piliers
de la solidarité dans notre société ne
laissons pas passer cette occasion
l'amendement de Madame Panis offre une
perspective de sortie j'ai envie de dire
par le haut et dans l'honneur pour
l'ensemble de notre assemblé et c'est
une un geste qui à l'évidence est ATT et
ser compris par nos
concitoyens merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur signé pour expliquer son
vote avez la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le
Ministre on va parler de de ce problème
qui est lié au aux femmes puisque ça a
été soulevé par le gouvernement qui a
voulu montrer faire un geste qu'il
assimile à un cadeau faire reculer l'âge
légal aujourd'hui fixé à 60 ans jusqu'à
67 ans pour avoir une retraite
décente pour alors que beaucoup de de de
femmes en particulier puisqueon parle de
femmes ne sont plus un activité non
parce qu'elles ont souhaité cesser leur
activité mais parce que leurs employeurs
nont plus voul les employés c'estd non
plus voulu d'elle la prolongation à 67
ans est tout à fait inacceptable quel
que soit l'âge où l'on a commencé son
travail l'amendement gouvernemental
exonérant de 2 années supplémentaires
les femmes qui ont élevé trois enfants
ou un enfant handicapé pourrait paraître
aller dans le bon sens en réalité en
réalité c'est de la poudre aux yeux pour
faire accepter d'inacceptable en
l'occurrence le report de départ de
l'âge de départ de la retraite à 67 ans
pour pour ceux ou celles qui n'ont pas
leur compte nannuité sans avoir
forcément élevé trois enfants d'ailleurs
ce chiffre de 3 me paraît parfaitement
arbitraire et il est il s'explique pour
palier l'absence de structure d'accueil
pour les jeunes
enfants après 60 ans
beaucoup trop épuisé et préfèrent partir
en retraite même avec une décote et ce
ne sont pas les deux années pour un
nombre très limité de femmes
d'ailleurs présenté comme un cadeau qui
ne mérite aucune
gratitude qui influeront sur un choix
dicté par une overdose de travail
exténuant d'ailleurs à vrai dire il n'y
a pas de cadeau puisque l'on en revient
à la position
actuelle à 65 ans de 65 ans en dehors du
petit TR de un petit écran pour les
personnes pour les femmes qui sont nées
entre mi 51 et fin 55 aucun changement
aucune amélioration en vérité en dehors
de cette
petite de cette très courte période on
peut s'étonner monsieur le ministre que
cette mesure a pu satisfaire un certain
nombre de sénateurs le pire n'est jamais
sûr mais la solution proposée est loin
d'être satisfait présente n'est-il pas
n'est-il pas particulièrement cynique de
miser sur le fait que certaines
personnes partiront plôt qu'à l'âge
légal donc avec une ncote des côtes et
une pension encore plus faible afin de
réduire en partie les problèmes
financiers de votre système de retraite
on peut remarquer que ce sont les femmes
qui ont souvent dû cesser leur travail
pour élever des enfants or ce sont ces
enfants qui travailleront un jour pour
payer la retraite des plus favorisés qui
nont jamais dû interrompre leur parcours
professionnel limitez votre geste qui se
croit généreux aux femmes ayant eu TR
enfant ou un enfant handicapé est un peu
de sucre mis sur une pilule àè mais
neuant en rien
l'amertume de la pilule par ailleurs un
mot tout de même parce qu'elle a des
conséquences sur leur retraite et on le
mesure aujourd'hui il faut insister sur
l'insertion des jeunes sur le marché du
travail qui doit être une priorité on
doit renforcer les formations
professionnelles et valider les droits à
la retraite pour les jeunes qui sont en
stage en fin de compte monsieur le
ministre votre projet instore une
redistribution à l'envers l'injustice en
est évidente puisque les plus modes
devront bénéficier d'une plus grande qui
devrait bénéficier d'une plus grande
protection payeront pour ceux qui ont eu
des carrières plus facile ce n'est pas
de la solidarité les Français quittent
le travail le marché du travail en
moyenne à 58 ans n'oublions pas cela à
58 ans et se retrouve au chômage jusqu'à
ce qu'il puissent bénéficier de le
retraite à tau plein reculer l'âge légal
revient à imposer un chômage de longue
durée plus plus long aux indemnités de
chômage succédera l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique puis le RSA AF de
pouvoir bénéficier d'une retraite sans
décôes beaucoup on l'a dit abandonne
fatigué ulcéré faut-il trouver cela
normal je m merci mon cher collègue
monsieur le Président belle pour
explication de vote vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président
oui merci monsieur le Président je crois
qu'il est qu'il est bien que nous
puissions passer un peu de temps sur am
de Madame Panis parce qu'il est très
révélateur du du débat qui est le notre
ce matin dans dans cette assemblée alors
bien entendu nous les sénateurs de
gauche et notamment du groupe socialiste
nous avons dès le début expliquer quelle
était notre ligne de conduite et
aujourd'hui nous sommes face à un point
particulier sur lequel le gouvernement a
voulu donner l'impression de faire des
concessions l'é lisé me dit-on de mini
concession mais je pense que certaines
questions sont posées et l'amendement de
Madame Panis de la délégation des droits
des femmes ici au Sénat je pense pose la
question essentielle pourquoi limiter
cette mesure au à trois enfants et en
réalité moi je pense qu'il y a une forme
de contradiction de la part du
gouvernement la contradiction elle est
au fur à mesure que le débat S slifi que
oui la mobilisation sociale se
manifestait au fur à mesure des des des
débats au Parlement à l'Assemblée dans
les conditions que vous connaissez puis
maintenant au Sénat le gouvernement a
voulu donner le sentiment de faire une
ouverture la contradiction est qu'il est
tellement timoré dans cette ouverture
qu'à mon sens elle elle pose problème
alors je me demande s'il est possible
moment où nous exprimons d'essayer de le
faire les uns et les autres et notamment
du côté du gouvernement sans vision
dogmatique car on l'a bien vu vous êtes
lié par deux impératifs je dirais un
impératif médiatique et puis ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un impératif financier
dont il faudrait se départir l'impératif
médiatique c'est le tempo le calendrier
que le Président de la République a
voulu imposer qui nous nous a été
rappelé tout au long de la semaine
dernière il fallait
absolument voter les deux articles
article 5 les article 6 avant le weekend
je pense que les uns et les autres nous
avons pris conscience dans le débat que
cela n'était pas possible et que les les
questions posées étaient tellement
importantes qu'il fallait y consacrer y
consacrer du temps et je crois
aujourd'hui que vous auriez aussi
avantage à ne pas avoir les yeux rivés
sur cette communication on a un peu
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les textes
de loi sont se déroulent en fonction
bien sûr de la mobilisation une
manifestation le 12 octobre peut-être
une autre plus tard il y en a eu
beaucoup jusqu'à présent et vous savez
pour à chaque fois réunir près de 3
millions de personnes dans les rues il
faut vraiment que les Français
ressentent ce sujet comme un élément
premier de leur préoccupation vous avez
vu les sondages même si ils ne sont
qu'un indicateur les les sondages encore
ce matin alors même que les Français ont
à souffrir de cette situation lorsqu'ils
ont à se déplacer lorsqu'ils ont à faire
des
efforts pour faire une journée de grève
qui leur coûte beaucoup dans leur dans
leur revenu aujourd'hui et bien près de
70 % des Français même 70 % des Français
ne sont pas d'accord avec le
gouvernement et ils sont presque aussi
nombreux à vouloir que la mobilisation
sociale continue pour faire entendre un
message et je pense que ce message vous
vous pourriez monsieur le ministre
l'entendre l'entendre ce matin
et écouter aussi l'amendement de de
Madame Panis ce que ce que cela recouvre
pour dire que oui vous non seulement
vous êtes dans une posture médiatique
mais aussi vous avez une attitude
humaine et que vous êtes capable en
effet de comprendre des arguments
lorsqu'ils vous sont énoncés avec calme
et lorsqu'ils sont éteayés par des
arguments sérieux alors la deuxième
contrainte c'est c'est la
contrainte financière puisque vous vous
vous y avez fait appel sur la base des
éléments démographiques depuis le début
alors quelquefois on dit l'argent on le
trouve ben l'argent vous le savez
aujourd'hui vous pouvez le trouver au
travers de la remise en cause du du
bouclier fiscal et le Premier ministre
semble-t-il a ouvert une brèche sur sur
ce sujet je pense que les les deux
choses d'une certain manière peuvent
être liés monsieur le ministre je crois
peut-être qu'il faudrait si cela doit
prendre du temps àjournner des décisions
lourdes pour les mères de famille
notamment sur cette question de façon à
aller dans le sens de ce qu' aujourd'hui
vous vous semblez admettre une remise à
plat à la fois du bouclier fiscal mais
aussi de cette réforme et notamment de
ce point essentiel de l'âge de départ
sans déquotes à 65 ans merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président fich
cher pour expliquer son vote
oui monsieur le Président je crois que
l'amendement de Madame Panis et Annie
David bien sûr a indiqué que notre
groupe le voterait car je crois qu'il
est plein de bon sens car il tient à la
fois compte de deux choses bon des
interruptions de carrière et puis que
d'autre part il tient compte aussi de
l'évolution et bien de notre société et
à partir de là du vieillissement de la
population française et de toutes les
conséquences que cela entraînera
donc aujourd'hui il convient de rappeler
mais nous l'avons dit et redit que les
inégalités bien touchent plus
particulièrement les femmes les
inégalités ce sont les femmes d'abord et
que tous les trous d'ailleurs dans les
carrièresin elles
sont plus particulièrement touchées par
ces ruptures par des carrières hachées
du à la vie professionnelle mais aussi à
la vie familiale aux contraintes de plus
en plus grande et on peut s'imaginer
dans le cadre de la réflexion que l'on
aura sur la loi sur la dépendance et
bien on peut imaginer qu'elle jouont un
rôle
important et là on voit bien que ce qui
qui aujourd'hui nous est proposé et bien
est largement insuffisant et c'est
absolument conforter ces inégalités
alors je rappelle que les trous dans les
carrières n'expliquent pas loin sans
faux la totalité de la différence de
niveau de pension en ne s'en tenant
qu'au carrière complète l'écart en 2004
slevait encore à 36 % et on voit que
dans les années qui ont suivi et bien
céta écart de 40 % est toujours maintenu
car si les femmes travaillent plus
longtemps que leurs aînés bon des
générations précédentes et bien elles
occupent aussi plus souvent des emplois
à temps partiel cela a été rappelé elles
sont plus souvent au chômage et elles
perçoivent des salaires inférieurs à
ceux des hommes donc
20 % en moyenne et c'est situation
entraîne des écarts de salairire de
référence qui se répercutent ensuite sur
le niveau de la pension et écart qui
risque de durer car si en matière de
durée d'assurance l'écart se réduit au
fil des génération selon les projections
de laacnav et bien il reste il passerait
hors MDA c'est-à-dire en majoration de
durée d'assurance de 18 trimestres pour
la génération 1900 150 à 10 trimestres
et pourra être négatif
alors quand on regarde le salaire de
référence et bien son mode de calcul
aussi influe sur les conséquences et sur
le calcul des pensions puisque ce
salaire de référence et bien est de 34 %
60 était encore de 27 % et il se réduit
très très lentement donc je crois que
les conséquences aussi sur les retraites
complémentaires seront dans le même sens
et c'est pour cela qu'il apparaît
important et bien de voter cet
amendement et non pas avoir une position
qui est incompréhensible pour les
Françaises et les Français et qui montre
bien quelle est la volonté du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire d'une manière
ou d'une autre de remettre en cause tout
notre système de protection sociale à
commencer par celui des
retraites
madame la Présidente Nicole bveau pour
expliquer son vote merci monsieur le
Président alors l'amendement de Madame
Panis qui recoupe ce qui était partagé à
minima
par notamment l'Observatoire de la
parité où comme chacun sait il n'y a pas
parité entre la majorité et
l'opposition puisque la majorité y est
majoritaire et donc c'était quand Mme
même le disons
le tout le monde était d'accord sur le
fait que au minimum il devait y avoir
une mesure pour les femmes quand je dis
pour les femmes c'est-à-dire l'ensemble
des femmes pour le moins qui avait qui
avait eu au moins un enfant donc là on
voit que vous faites totalement obstacle
avec votre amendement que vous avez
présenté
comme vraiment une façon d'entendre le
mécontentement vous voulez désamorcer le
mécontentement il y a tout à craindre
pour vous que avec cette mesurette que
nous nous faisons fort d'expliquer vous
accroissiez le mécontentement et des
femmes et de l'ensemble de de la
population car en effet diviser les
femmes de cette façon-là euh cibler
votre euh votre disons euh cadeau pour
une si faible proportion de la
population féminine c'estéit contraire à
toute réalité en effet comme j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de vous le dire les femmes
dans leur ensemble avant même qu'elles
aient des enfants dès lors qu'elles
peuvent avoir des enfants puisque on
considère que c'est c'est pas une chance
que les femmes fassent des enfants mais
c'est pour le patronat c'est
un c'est un handicap en quelque sorte
avant même qu'elles aient des enfants et
quasiment jusqu'à l'âge de 35 ans quand
elles sont embauchées elles sont
soumises à des salaires inférieurs et
des carrières plus difficiles parce
qu'on leur dit vous allez vous arrêter
pour faire des enfants ça c'est avir
même qu'elles en aient alors ensuite
quand elles en ont évidemment ça
s'aggrave ce qui légitime en quelque
sorte pour le patronat le fait qu'elle
soit payée moins que les hommes et
ensuite quand quand elles arrivent à 50
ans comme les hommes d'ailleurs elles ne
trouvent plus d'emploi hein parce que
une femme qui s'est arrêtée et qui
reprendrait son travail à 50 ans et ben
bonjour les dégâs pour qui veut
reprendre son travail à 50 ans bonjour
les dégâts pour trouver à être embauché
donc dire qu'on va cibler simplement les
femmes de d'une demigénération en
quelque sorte c'est-à-dire de 51 à 55 ça
fait la moitié de d'âge et pour qui ont
eu trois enfants qui ont le nombre de un
nombre de trimestres donné qui ont
travaillé avant qui ont repris le
travail après c'est méconnaître
complètement la réalité alors
vous si vous voulez vous
mettez vous ne faites que répéter depuis
le début que la question est uniquement
financière donc vous faites fille
évidemment du droit à la retraite vous
faites de la situation réelle des hommes
et des femmes d'ailleurs et surtout du
fait que à partir de de au-delà de 50
ans il ne trouvent plus d'emploi où ils
sont
simplement licenciés par ce qu'il coûte
trop cher et vous ne parlez que de
financement je vous fais observer que
nous avons déposé un certain nombre de
sous-amendements qui ont très justement
au financement à des moyens de trouver à
financer notre système de retraite
notamment par euh des mesures qui
contreviendraient au privilèges insensés
euh des euh ceux qui gagnent le plus et
qui ont des revenus autres que ceux du
travail vous refusez de discuter du
financement donc ça aussi c'est une
question qui est incompréhensible
puisque nous sommes ici au Parlement et
donc nous avons légitimité à vouloir à
contester ce que vous dites sur le
financement et à proposer d'autres
sources de financement voilà donc à
minimum je crois que il faut quand même
faire droit aux femmes à minimum et ne
pas diviser entre celles qui ont sont né
entre 51 et
entre 51 et 55 et celles qui ont eu un
ou plusieurs enfants et celles qui ont
pris commencé le travail avant d'avoir
des enfants et celles qui ont eu des
enfants après l'avoir
commencé madame Campion pour expliquer
son
vote merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues je voudrais à mon tour attirer
l'attention de chacun sur cette
proposition qui nous est faite par
Madame
Panis
propositionun sous-amendement qui est
totalement justifié qui est le reflet du
point de vue de nos collègues qui
siègent à la délégation au droits des
femmes et qui bien renforcer
encore les éléments que nous avons pu
développer autour déjà de cet article 6
qui est le cœur de la réforme que vous
nous proposez avec ce passage de 65 à 67
ans et qui est particulièrement injuste
notamment pour les
femmes et donc également de de de cet
amendement que le gouvernement nous a
proposé jeudi matin alors madame
Panis nous propose que l'on maintienne à
65 ans l'âge de départ à leur à la
retraite pour toute femme quelle que
soit son année de naissance
effectivement et elle a raison quand on
voit qu'on nous
propose le gouvernement nous propose de
cibler les personnes qui sont nées entre
le 1er juillet 51 et le 31 décembre 55
cette porte à peine entrouverte sur ce
qui représente 4 années et demi même pas
5 années comme on a trop tendance à à le
dire 4 années et demi qu'est-ce que ça
représente euh madame Panis nous propose
donc que ça soit appliqué à à toute
personn quelle que soit cette son année
de naissance qui ce soit occupé d'un ou
de plusieurs enfants
effectivement ce que le ministre nous a
proposé c'est que on ne s'attache et on
ne s'arrête que aux personnes qui ont eu
ou élevé au moins trois enfants ensuite
de cela euh elle a raison d'attirer
notre attention sur toutes les personnes
qui se sont interrompu dans leur
carrière professionnelle pour être
auprès du membre de leur famille qu'il
soi handicapés qu'il soient dépendant ou
qu'il soi malade euh les propositions
qui nous ont été euh faites par le
gouvernement je le répète sont une porte
à peine
entrouverte 4 ans et demi trois enfants
avoir validé également un nombre de
trimestre minimum quel est ce nombre de
trimestres minimum avant cette
interruption euh de de carrière avoir
interrompu également cette son activité
dans des conditions et un délai
déterminé beaucoup de de questions
beaucoup
d'incertitudes qui font que très peu de
personnes très peu non concitoyens vont
être concernés par cette proposition
quoi que l'on puisse annoncer quoi que
l'on puisse dire euh et quoi que le
gouvernement veuille faire croire à nos
concitoyens depuis euh jeudi cette
annonce
on nous dit que après 1955 voire après
1960 le nombre de trimestres
euh validé par les femmes va dépasser
celui validé par les hommes nous savons
tous que ça n'est pas le cas c'est un
argument fallacieux et que les hommes
notamment ont des trimestres qui vont de
en manière de manière dégressive qui
sont moins importants parce que le
chômage à ce moment-là a commencé à T à
toucher nos concitoyens donc pour toutes
ces
raisons l'amendement de Madame panist
est parfaitement venu il permettra
d'être de rétablir un petit peu plus de
justice notamment pour les femmes
concerné et donc mes chers collègues je
vous invite vraiment à ce que nous
l'adoptions et monsieur le ministre je
vous invite à à suivre la proposition de
notre commission se prononçant sur la
sagesse du Sénat et et et soyons sages
et adoptons l'amendement de Madame Panis
ce matin madame Odette TER pour
expliquer son vote vous avez la parole
mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président
beaucoup de choses ont déjà été dites
mais votre amendement monsieur le
ministre ne règle en rien la situation
d'inégalité vécue par de trop nombreuses
femmes laissez croire que vous proposez
une sorte de révolution avec cet cet
amendement et et est purement mensonger
quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui les femmes
sont les premières victimes de cette
réforme injuste qu'elles subissent déjà
des profondes inégalités dans le niveau
des pensions donc leur pensions qui sont
en moyenne 65 % de celles des hommes et
seulement 50 % si on retranche les
pensions de reversion donc que le
problème effectivement vient des
inégalités salariales des inégalités au
cours de la vie active et qu'il faudrait
effectivement tenter d'y d'y d'y
contribuer mais aujourd'hui la réforme
en repoussant les les bornes d'âge à 62
et à
67 ne ne règle en rien cet amendement
non plus et donc c'est pourquoi il faut
vraiment voter pour l'amendement de
notre collègue Jacqueline Panis qui est
un amendement qui a été proposé y
compris dans le cadre de la délégation
au droits des femmes de notre délégation
au droits des femmes je je veux citer
aussi que cette inégalité faite aux
femmes est reconn par tous y compris par
la Halde et que donc en conséquence cet
amendement de notre collègue est en
quelque sorte un amendement de repli sur
la situation actuelle mais qu'il nous
faut absolument le voter et c'est
pourquoi je le voterai mon monsieur
Dauge pour expliquer son vote vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue
merci merci monsieur le Président pour
expliquer mon vote je dirais que cet
amendement ouvre la voix à une vraie
réflexion sur le travail voyez je trouve
que tout le débat que nous avons depuis
plusieurs jours euh escamote euh une
réflexion de
fond à mon avis elle viendra qu'est-ce
que le travail aujourd'hui dans notre
société et
euh nous avons là un un texte qui ne
prend pas en compte cette réflexion
monsieur le ministre quand vous avez
répondu à Pierre morroi euh en lui
disant oui mais le monde a changé
l'autre jour quand il vous disait nous
étions sur la ligne de l'espérance vous
avez dit Monsieur monsieur le Premier
ministre le le le le monde de l'emploi
le monde a changé depuis depuis 30 ans
c'est vrai mais il a changé comment le
monde quantitativement vous savez nous
avons un taux de chômage qui est plutôt
supérieur à ce que nous avions en 81 et
qualitativement le changement du monde
du travail est considérable
et nous ne le prenons pas en compte moi
je crois qu'il y a là une réflexion qui
comme bien des sujets qui sont évoqué
entre nous ce matin dépasse
totalement nos oppositions et cet
amendement ouvre la voix à une question
essentielle comment et le rapporteur mon
collègue Dominique Leclerc le connaît
bien ce
sujet des personnes âgées des handicapés
euh qui va s'en occuper dans notre
société et comment allons-nous prendre
en compte euh le temps de travail des
personnes qui vont se consacrer à à la
question du handicap à la question de la
dépendance et c'est là qu'effectivement
on va retrouver le rôle central des
femmes pas uniquement des femmes mais
quand même le rôle central des femmes on
va pas échapper à cette question hein
elle est elle est devant nous et ce qui
est intéressant que c'est cet amendement
bon il pose ce problème et et il nous
questionne tous
donc moi je crois que alors le
gouvernement a pensé
faire une ouverture dans ce sens très
bien mais moi je crois qu'il faut aller
plus loin
et je souhaite vivement que l'assemblée
ce matin notre assemblée ce matin puisse
aller dans cette direction et puis la la
direction que j'indique sur une vraie
réflexion de fond sur le monde du
travail aujourd'hui s'engage pour que
nous puissions revenir ensuite sur le
sujet et traduire les conclusions de nos
réflexions dans un texte qui sera alors
amélioré
merci question de vote monsieur le
ministre vous
souhaitiez merci Monsieur le le
président oui juste quelques mots parce
que c'est un sousamendement qui appelle
à à parler de l'amendement du du
gouvernement euh pourquoi pourquoi trois
enfants parce que ça répond à la
question posée la question posée c'est
où y y a-t-il inégalité entre les hommes
et les femmes c'est ça la question où y
a-t-il inégalité en terme de trimestre
entre les hommes et les femmes
l'inégalité quand on regarde le dossier
il faut faut juste regarder le dossier
quand on ge le dossier l'inégalité elle
est sur les générations que nous avons
évoqué et c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement a pris cette cette cette
décision de vous présenter cette cet
amend
on on se rend compte d'ailleurs que pour
les femmes qui ont un enfant ou deux
enfants le taux d'emploi est bien plus
élevé c'est au 3è enfant que le taux
décroche c'est c'est l'INC le mesure le
corps a publié en 2008 toute une série
de de d'évaluation là-dessus c'est au
3oè enfant que le taux d'emploi en
réalité chute beaucoup et c'est
évidemment dans ces générations là très
de de personne n'allant partir à la
retraite à partir de l'année prochaine
c'est dans ces générations là que les
femmes ont moins de trimestre que les
hommes et c'est pour cela que le
gouvernement dépose cet amendement qui
n'est pas un cadeau vous avez une façon
un peu comme ça un peu des unvolte dit
c'est un c'est un cadeau c'est pas c'est
pas ni un cadeau ni pas un cadeau c'est
une mesure c'est une mesure une nouvelle
mesure une mesure encore d' une mesure
d'équité vis-à-vis de la population
féminine je voudrais quand même vous
dire que
euh on peut pas on peut pas fois dire il
faut réformer les retraites et puis en
même temps se dire il n'y a il n'y a que
des exceptions à la réforme des
retraites je il faut bien qu'il y ait un
système général qui nous permette
d'équilibrer notre système de retraite
alors je sais que c'est difficile et que
vous ne voulez pas écouter ses propos
que au fond il peut y avoir autant de
déficit qu'on veut c'est pas si grave
que ça mais c'est pas notre position
notre position c'est une position de
responsabilité et de responsabilité
vis-à-vis des Français sauver le système
de de retraite c'est la première des
justices c'est au contraire ne pas
sauver le système de retraite qui est la
première des injustices et qui paye la
première des injustices si le système de
retraite était pas financé c'est au fond
le système de solidarité à l'intérieur
de la retraite il y a 30 milliards
d'euros 30 milliards d'euros qui est au
sein de la CNAV au travers du FSV des
autres mesures c'est-à-dire du régime
général 30 milliards d'euros qui finance
la solidarité dans le système de de
retraite c'est-à-dire les les
majorations durée d'assurance
c'est-à-dire les congés parentaux
c'est-à-dire le la prise en compte du
chômage c'est 30 milliards d'euros là
c'est-à-dire exactement le niveau du
déficit exactement le niveau du déficit
global de l'ensemble des régimes de de
retraite si nous voulons conserver notre
régime de retraite c'est-à-dire la
solidarité à l'intérieur de ce ce régime
il faut faire évoluer ce ce système de
retraite et si vous à force d'amendement
ou de sous-amendement vous ne mettez que
des exceptions que des exceptions à la
réforme au fond il y a plus de réforme
il y a plus de réforme si vous
considérez que sur toute la population
féminine il faut pouvoir rester à 65 ans
c'est certainement extrêmement généreux
sauf que ça met en péril le régime de
retraite et quand on met en péril le
régime de retraite on met en péril
l'ensemble des Français l'ensemble des
Français alors nous devons prendre des
mesure c'est ce que nous avons fait pour
les chômeurs pour les personnes
handicapées c'est ce que nous faisons
pour les femmes parce que elles
souffrent d'une inéquité flagrante en
dans ces dans ces annéesl al faut pas en
rester là il faut faire d'autres choses
pour la population madame Panis a bien
raison il faut faire d'autres choses il
faut notamment s'attaquer à l'inégalité
salariale madame borvoau bien sûr qu'il
faut s'attaquer à
l'inégalité salariale ça fait des années
qu'on cherche à s'y attaquer et ça fait
des années probablement qu'il y a pas de
résultat sur le sujet ben nous devrons
avoir des des résultats et dans ce texte
j'espère que vous le voterez d'ailleurs
j'espère je suis sûr que vous le voterez
dans ce texte il y a une une sanction
financière vis-à-vis des des des
entreprises nous devons aussi faire en
sorte que les femmes puissent avir avoir
un vrai choix entre travailler ou ne pas
travailler quand on a des enfants et moi
je pense par exemple mais je pourrais
citer d'autres exemples à la mesure qui
est d'augmenter le nombre de places de
de crèche en France c'est-à-dire d'avoir
le choix à ce moment-là entre mettre son
enfant dans une crèche ou ne pas le
mettre et rester au foyer et lorsqu'on
crée 200000 places de crèche dans les
années qui viennent en France 100000
chez les nourriss et 100000 dans les
places de de crèche qu'ell soit publique
ou privé c'est évidemment là encore une
fois une avancée vers le libre choix car
le libre choix c'est aussi d'avoir une
société qui vous permette en réalité de
répondre aux besoins et c'est bien c'est
bien c'est bien cela dont dont il s'agit
alors vous nous disiez il faut avoir du
cœur je l'ai entendu je pas reprendre
une célèbre expression sur le monopole
mais je crois pas que le débat se pose
comme ça tout le monde a envie que nos
concitoyens il vivent plus heureux qu' a
plus d'emploi qu'on ait plus de de
capacité au fond à développer sa vie
personnelle dans les les meilleurs des
conditions mais pour faire cela il faut
juste que nos lois il faut juste que nos
nos nos systèmes de protection sociale
tiennent le choc et évolue en même temps
que la société tout entière et c'est ce
que nous faisons au travers des
retraites nous voulons un système de
retraite qui permettent à chacune et à
chacun d'avoir une retraite financée sur
du long terme dans des conditions
claires et c'est pour ça qu'il faut la
faire évoluer c'est pour ça madame
panisque nous sommes sensibles à votre
argument nous préférions que ce
sous-amendement soit retiré mais je
pense que ce que propose le gouvernement
est exactement la question qui a été
posée les femmes ont moins de trimestre
que les hommes quels sont les femmes qui
ont moins de trimestre que les hommes
nous répondons à cette question très
précise pas
d'observation particulière monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président si vous
le permettez parce que je crois que sur
les documents figure un avis de sagesse
et je voudrais rappeler en 2 secondes
l'avis de la position le l'avis pardon
de la commission lorsque nous avons
étudié cet amendement tout d'abord c'est
sûr on a écouté madame André elle a
rapporté très brièvement les principales
conclusions
donc de sa présidence et Dieu sait si
elles sont partagées mais je crois que
Madame Tasca a
parlé et c'est très intéressant de
toutes ces inégalités cumulées pour la
reprendre essentiellement par les femmes
mais elle nous a déjà suggéré que la
principale réponse ou les
les réponses les plus importantes
devaient apporter au moment où justement
ces inégalités sont supportées par les
familles je dirait et notamment en terme
en charge
d'éducation et ça c'est très important
et c'est sûr que yvdo je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure bien sûr la vie a changé la vie
la société a changé et
aujourd'hui non mais les réponses que
nous devons apporter en terme de
retraite on doit les apporter aussi en
terme de vieillissement de la population
et les réponses ont des financements et
dans quelques semaines nous serons
apportés à réfléchir pour apporter des
ces améliorations en terme de prise en
charge de la maladie des personnes âgées
de la dépendance vous l'avez dit et de
leur logement et si le volet dans notre
système par répartition contributif est
déjà très important monsieur le ministre
a évoquer 30 milliards on connaît tous
ces chiffres et bien on le sait la
retraite ne peut pas résoudre répondre à
toutes ces inégalités et elles sont les
retraites les reflets de la vie
professionnelle nous sommes dans un
système essentiellement contributif
voilà un petit peu donc aujourd'hui
madame Panis nous rapporte un un
amendement qui fait c'est vrai
disparaître je le dis la plupart des
conditions exigées pour bénéficier de la
mesure proposé par le gouvernement bien
sûr il serait beaucoup plus coûteux très
coûteux sans pour cela comme je viens de
le dire avoir des effets significatifs
sur la situation des femmes et
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne ce projet
de loi on le sait le problème n'est pas
obligatoirement tout le temps un nombre
de trimestres mais essentiellement dû et
on a parler de 38 % de cet écart he
consécutif
entre les hommes et les femmes à des
vies professionnelles à des inégalités
salariales et je crois que dans le
projet il y a une forte avancée donc
pour conclure sur ce point pour conclure
monsieur le Président donc la commission
des affaires sociales avait émis un avis
défavorable attendez ça figure dans le
Bulletin des commissions je viens de
regarder
bon n très bien N
renvoyer nous allons maintenant passer
au vote si vous le voulez bien non vous
avez
déjà expliquez votre vote il y a pas
deux explications de
vote
bien mes chers collègues j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe de l'Union pour un mouvement
populaire sur le sous-amendement numéro
1200 de Madame Panis tendant à modifier
l'amendement
1182 les avis viennent d'être raelés
tant par le gouvernement que par la
commission il va être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour s'il vous
plaît ceux qui souhaitent voter
pour remettrons au secrétaire un
bulletin blanc contre un bulletin bleu
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir
remettront un bulletin
rouge s'il vous
plaît secrétaire sont en
place je vous
Enie le scrutin est
ouvert
ver
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est donc cl j'invite Madame et
Monsieur le Secrétaire a bien vouloir
procéder au
dépouillement
résultat du scrutin qui porte le numéro
13 sur le sous-amendement
1200 à l'amendement
1182 à l'article 6 du projet de loi
portant réforme des retraites le nombre
de votants
336 nombre de suffrages exprimés 335 la
majorité absolue des suffrages exprimés
s'établie à 168 pour l'adoption 158
contre 177 le Sénat n'a donc pas
adopté
alors nous passons à l'amendement
sous-amendement
on4 madame la présidente madame David le
défendation
oui défend explication de vote
excusez-moi madame
Pasquet
que nous allons explications deun vote
sur l'amendement de sous-amendement 1184
et le sous-amendement 1197 qui sont
identiques
oui madame merci monsieur le
Président au travers de cette
explication de vote je voudrais
simplement rappeler que notre groupe n'a
pas
eu loisir de défendre les
sous-amendements financiers c'était nous
avions des proposition qui apportait
immédiatement des pistes de
financement ces amendements donc
s'inscrivent s'inscrivent dans une
logique de désintoxication financière de
notre
économie car la situation est telle
qu'aujourd'hui les grands patrons de
ceux qui bénéficient des stock options
des actions gratuites ou des parachutes
dorées ont tout à attendre de
l'instabilité économique comme le
soulligne Christian chavanux dans le
magazine alternative économique de
juillet août 2010 pratiquement 2 ans et
demi après la crise qu'est-ce qui a
changé a priori rien les marchés
continuent de spéculer à cœur joie ils
profitent d'une instabilité qu'ils sont
les premiers à entretenir car plus il y
a de volatilité plus il y a de Paris à
faire et plus il y a de l'argent à
gagner et de rajouter et comme il
gagneent effectivement beaucoup d'argent
les bonus suivent si rien n'a changé
depuis 2 ans c'est que contrairement aux
déclarations du président de la
République faite à New York loin des
pressions du MDEF français les règles
n'ont pas changé et ne changeront pas la
finance au service de l'économie venté
devant l'ONU est une chimère et cette
loi en est la preuve contrairement à ce
que vous tentez de dire n'est pas juste
comment pourrait-il en être autrement
quand les marchés financiers se gavent
sur le dos des salariés sans qu'aucune
barrière ne soit instaurée loin de vos
discours rassurant vous continuez à
laisser les mains libres aux
financiers et cela produit des scandales
que nos concitoyens à raison ne
supporent plus prime de bienvenue bonus
action gratuite stock option parachute
doré retraite chapeau la panoplie est
fournie et usée jusqu'à la corde je
pense particulièrement au salariés de
Valéo qui ont découvert le montant
astronomique du parachute doré accordé à
leur patron Thierry Morin qui a
bénéficié d'un cadeau de départ de 3,2
milliards d'euros alors qu'il laisse
derrière lui un déficit de 200000 d'Ur
et laisse sur le carreau 1600 salariés
un parachute doré auquel il convient de
rajouter les 900000 € annuels de
retraite chapeau qu'il percevra chaque
année jusqu'à la fin de sa vie cette
pratique qui là encore déconnecte
entièrement la rémunération des
dirigeants de leur réussite en terme de
gestion n'est tout simplement plus
acceptable sur le plan économique comme
sur le plan de la justice sociale que
vous appelez morale sur le plan
économique d'abord car ces sommes
parfois colossal donné au PDG manque
naturellement à l'investissement des
entreprises qui en ont besoin là encore
nous nous souvenions du discours de
Nicolas Sarkozi sur la règle du partage
en 3ois tiers nous étions sceptiques
mais nous constatons surtout aujourd'hui
que de ce principe vous n'en parlez plus
le partage aujourd'hui c'est tous tout
pour les patrons et rien pour les
salariés d'ailleurs si les parachutes
dorées échappent en partie aux
cotisations sociales les salariés
licenciés quant à eux payent bien des
cotisations sur leur indemnité de
licenciement sur le plan de la justice
sociale enfin cette pratique n'est plus
acceptable au nom de quoi un dirigeant
qui touche parfois des subventions
publiques laisse des entreprises dans
une situation exemple devrait percevoir
pour cette mauvaise gestion un parachute
doré rien ne le justifie raison pour
laquelle nous vous avions proposer ce
sous-amendement merci monsieur le prés
Monsieur S pour expliquer son vote puis
madame Le
Texier merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ce qui caractérise ce projet
nous l'avons dit depuis une semaine
c'est son
injustice voyez-vous vous n'avez jamais
répondu monsieur le ministre une
question très
simple dans le financement de la réforme
que vous proposez
90 % est porté par les revenus des
salaires des salariés 10 % par les
revenus du capital de la rente ou de la
spéculation est-ce
juste vous savez bien que non tout le
monde sait que non et d'ailleurs depuis
que nous assistons à ces débats nous
n'avons entendu personne nous expliquer
que ce soit juste si certains pensent
que c'est juste et bien il pourrait
développer une argumentation pour nous
convaincre
ou pour tenter de nous convaincre alors
peut-être les chiffres que je viens de
citer 90 % 10 % sont-ils inexacts dans
ce cas-là j'aimerais bien que le
gouvernement nous donne les chiffres les
chiffres qu'il penseent
justes mais je n'ai pas entendu de
contradiction par rapport à cela d'autre
part on nous dit mais vous
savez les fr
qui sont touchés par le bouclier fiscal
ils vont être mis à
contribution très bien mais seulement on
a calculé que ces Français soumis au
bouclier fiscal Péré entre 500 et 700 €
par
an donc monsieur ficher vous savez bien
cela madame Lilian
bancour remboursé par l'État au titre du
bouclier
fiscal 30 millions
d'euros beaucoup beaucoup Monsieur de
roi elle a payé beaucoup d'impôts mais
parce qu'elle avait aussi des revenus
considérable mais monsieur Jocelin deoan
et chers collègues est-ce que vous
pensez quand même qu'il est juste que
quelqu'un qui reçoit au titre du
bouclier fiscal C certes parce qu'elle
paie beaucoup d'impôts mais elle a aussi
beaucoup de revenus 30 millions
d'euros qu'on lui demande pour
contribuer à la retraite au financement
de la retraite de payer entre 500 et 700
€ comme dit Monsieur Jean-Louis carer
qui est très avisé il dit c'est comme la
quête franchement c'est les bonnes
œuvres
donc Monsieur Jean-Louis car est très
avisé comme toujours et donc monsieur le
ministre il y a quand même un problème
dans ce projet de loi c'est le problème
de la justice tout le monde le sait
alors par rapport à l'amendement
présenté par nos collègues du groupe
communiste républicain et
citoyen qui est identique à celui qui
sera présenté par le groupe socialiste
ce qui prouve une grande unité de vue et
bien nous proposons de supprimer les
mots nés entre le 1er juillet 19 1 et le
31 décembre
1955 inclus mais très franchement si
vous prenez cette mesure nous nous
trouvons que c'est absurde nous l'avons
expliqué longuement tout à l'heure de
réduire cela au seul cas des femmes
ayant eu trois enfants nous pensons que
cela peut s'appliquer à toutes les
femmes et ayant élevé des enfants ou un
enfant mais pourquoi cette restriction
dont a parlé avec éloquence madame
Blandin tout à l'heure et avec je crois
beaucoup de beaucoup de force de
conviction né entre le 1er juillet 1951
et le 31 décembre 1955 inclus on a
l'impression que lorsqu'il
s'agit de taxer ceux qui touchent le
bouclier fiscal là vous êtes très
parsimonieux et quand il s'agit des
femmes ayant élever des enfants vous
êtes particulièrement pingre hein donc
que voulez-vous né entre le 1er juillet
1951 et le 31 décembre 1955 inclus je
puis vous dire qu'il est très mal perçu
et si vous avez pensé que cette entre
guillemets concession serait de nature à
faire baisser la contestation et bien je
puis vous dire que c'est exactement le
contraire qui est en train de se
produire madame leexier pour expliquer
son
vote
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues je vais me répéter je vais
vous redire ce que nous avons dit et
redit vend vendredi et ce que déjà nous
vous disons depuis le début de cette
séance je vais me répéter mais sans
aucun complexe je ne vois pas pourquoi
il n'y aurait que le ministre qui se
répéterait en nous expliquant toujours
la même chose avec les mêmes arguments
pour justifier le fait que
finalement les femmes n'ont droit à rien
donc je rappelle tout de même les trois
clauses qui permettent à certaines
femmes de continuer de prendre leur
retraite sans décotes à 65 ans je le
répète d'autant plus que quand on lit
les médias pendant le weekend et bien on
s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas rentré dans
la tête de tout le monde donc d'abord il
faut être né en
1951 et 1955 deuxièmement il faut avoir
trois enfants troisièmement il faut
s'être arrêté pour é ses enfants mais à
condition d'avoir travaillé avant on a
démontré plusieurs fois qu'entre 51 et
55 les femmes se mariaent jeunes
qu'elles avaient des enfants tout de
suite et que pareil donc ell ne pouvaiit
pas travailler avant et que par ailleurs
l'entrée dans le monde du travail était
plutôt avant les à partir des années 60
donc s'agissant de ces deux amendements
du groupe communiste et du groupe
socialiste ces deux amendes ces deux
sous-amendements identique il s'agit là
de faire sauter la clause 51 à 55 on
comprend bien pourquoi vous avez mis en
place cette clause c'est qu'elle touche
très peu de femmes et de plus de plus
elle touche ça ne coûte pas cher je
d'ailleurs j'aimerais savoir comment
vous êtes arrivé et au nombre de femmes
et au coupt pour le gouvernement je suis
très sceptique euh par rapport à ça donc
euh ça ne coûte pas cher parce que ça
touche un minimum de femmes et de plus
ça touche des femmes qui précisément
vont réfléchir très sérieusement à leur
retraite qu'elles vont prendre 1 an 2
ans ou 3 ans après 2012 donc voilà des
raisons suppléments à partir de 2012
voilà donc des raisons supplémentaire
pour être attentif à cette petite
poignée de femme
euh
franchement monsieur le ministre si la
feuille de route ou les consignes qui
vous ont été donné par le Président de
la République sont les suivantes
et il faut il faut il faut laisser
croire qu'on lâche du
l'est trouvez-moi un
machin autour des des des femmes un
machin qui fasse du buzz et qui coûte
pas cher et bien mission accomplie je me
suis exprimée d'une manière
plus plutôt cavalière parce que sans
doute à tort j'imagine que le Président
de la République a pu s'adresser à vous
en ces
termes monsieur le Président
belle pour expliquer son vote
oui merci monsieur le Président moi bon
cet amendement nous nous renvoie un peu
au précédent puisque il est il est plus
large mais il y a quelque chose qui
m'inquiète et puis j'ai j'ai par
ailleurs un problème donc ce qui
m'inquiète ce sont les réactions du
ministre tout à l'heure puisque par
rapport à l'amendement qui é présenté
par Madame
Panis dans le fond il a dit ceux qui
sont vraiment attachés à une réforme des
retraites ne peuvent pas souscrire à des
amendements qui élargissent démesurément
le champ de ce que nous proposons
aujourd'hui alors moi je dis que c'est
faire bien peu de cas de nombreuses
personnalités sur ces banci de
l'assemblée de la majorité qui se sont
exprimés en formulant les choses très
différemment de ce que vient de le faire
le gouvernement et je vous ai écouté
monsieur le Président vous avez-vous
aussi proposé une tranche d'âge qui
n'était pas celle que le gouvernement a
retenu et qui se rapprochait plus de ce
que Madame Panis nous a proposé donc je
dis que le ministre fait bien peu de cas
à la fois des membres de la majorité
sénatoriale qui s'expriment d'une
certaine manière avec leur conscience en
toute liberté et d'autre part du
président du Sénat et puis j'ai un
problème parce que j'ai entendu le
rapporteur tout à l'heure et je pense
que ça il faudrait tout de même avoir
des explications puisque ça pu avoir une
influence sur le vote qui vient de se
dérouler nous dire que la Commission
avait émis un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement de Madame Panis alors vous
avez une liace mes chers collègu devant
vous avec le sous-amendement qui était
proposé par Madame Panis numéro
1200 il y a en haut à droite C et G C il
s'agit de la commission j'ai c'est le
gouvernement il est indiqué que la
Commission a demandé la sagesse du Sénat
et monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
indiqué qu'elle avait émis un vote
défavorable donc vraiment j'aimerais
comprendre bien madame brick pour
expliquer son vote puis monsieur le
Président
ficher un vrai problème merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre euh si
j'étais d'humeur à plaisanter en ce
lundi matin euh je mais le sujet est
grave vous le savez que j'y tiens à ce
sujet et euh vous euh vous n avvez un
problème avec les
femmes je vous ai rappelé dans la nuit
euh de jeudi à vendredi que vous leur
aviez quand même euh supprimé déjà la
demi la demipart fiscale qui sera
éteinte en
2014 et maintenant vous vous attaquez
vraiment à la à leur retraite alors je
crois
que la nation sononorait quand même
d'avoir une reconnaissance à l'endroit
des femmes elles ont apporté de
génération en génération après guerre et
même avant d'une certaine manière une
contribution fondamentale à l'économie
par leur travail et au soutien à la
croissance et aujourd'hui ah oui
personne n'en doute monsieur le
Président sauf que on voit bien que
quand on est au pied du mur on ne
franchit pas l'obstacle concernant leur
retraite elles ont apporté à la vie
sociale à la cohésion au vivre ensemble
et j'ai pas peur de le dire au sociétal
dans notre pays euh un service
incroyable tout en travaillant elles ont
et je vais après parler des générations
elles ont et particulièrement celle de
toute la génération d'après-gerre elles
ont euh élevé les enfants elles ont
travaillé et maintenant et maintenant on
le vole laite elle on leur vole leur
retraite et maintenant ce sont elles la
plupart du temps qui s'occupent de la
dépendance et qui s'occupe de leurs
vieux parents alors aujourd'hui euh vous
nous dites euh et bien on on veut 1er
juillet 1951 31 31 décembre
1955 et bien là j'ai quelques chiffres
monsieur le ministre sur l'interruption
d'activité des
Maes quand on prend les générations de
1954 à 1959
elle ne travaillent pas euh quand elles
ont eu trois enfants et je vous
reparlerai de la famille du critère
familial elle ne travaille plus à 68 %.
la génération de 60 69 elle ne travaille
plus à 68 %. la génération de
7085 elle ne travaille plus à 71 %.
alors pourquoi ce critère que nous
voulons supprimer par l'amendement de 51
à 55 est-ce que c'est un impératif
financier monsieur le ministre vous
étiez encore ministre du Budget quand
vous avez remis euh pour perte à la
Société Générale 1illard 700 millions
donc si vous voulez qu'on trouve de
l'argent on peut en trouver il y en a
pas énormément je connais l'état de nos
finances publiques mais on peut en
trouver mais il faut faire une vraie
réforme des retraites en même temps
qu'une vraie réforme fiscale et vous le
savez bien que l'un et l'autre sont
indissociable alors maintenant il me
semble que si ce n'est pas un impératif
if financier c'est un choix vous l'avez
dit les uns et les autres la semaine
dernière monsieur le Président Larcher
aussi dans une interview qu'il avait
donné avait dit je prendrai en compte on
prendra en compte l'impératif familial
les familles ont bondau parce que quand
il s'est agit d'ouvrir le travail du
dimanche vous vous êtes pas beaucoup
préoccupé des familles et du sort des
enfants hein il faut pas vous étonner
les mêmes qui demandent des sanctions
pour les parents qui n'accompliraient
pas leurs devoirs vis-à-vis de leurs
enfants et bien ils se sont pas beaucoup
préoccupés du sujet à ce moment-là alors
ne venez pas nous faire le coût de la
famille les chiffres je vous les ai je
vous les démonter font que cet argument
5155 ne tient pas et sur le plan
sociétal et social vous n'avez pas de
leçon familial à donner à la
gauche
merci monsieur le président ficher
peut-être madame vous vouliez intervenir
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente de la Commission monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je voulais
répondre à Monsieur belle sur la
question de l'Ave défavorable ou de la
sagesse alors nous avons bien la
confirmation que il y a eu un avis
défavorable on en était sûr mais je vous
le confirme d'autre part vendredi le
rapporteur a donné un avis qui est
repris dans la le contrerendu analytique
et qui est le suivant la commission a
donné un avis favorable aux deux
amendements du Gouvernement qui
répondent aux préoccupations du Sénat
elle est favorable au sous-amendement
numéro 1183 rectifié bis du président
Abou et du groupe usuc qui prend en
compte le cas des enfants handicapés
devenus adultes sagesse sur le
sous-amendement numéro
1199 du groupe socialiste défavorable
aux autres sous-amendements si la
Commission est suivie et cetera la
Commission avait amis des avis de
sagesse émis pardon des avis de sagesse
sur les amendems 37 38 248 rectifié 285
et 563 donc ça c'était la confirmation
de ce qui avait été décidé en
commission je ne suis pas responsable de
ce qui
est c'est une erreur et j'ai demandé
d'ailleurs qu'on viille bien procéder
dans le service concerné à l'enquête
nécessaire monsieur le Président
ficher nous étions très attentifs et
notamment à cette rectification monsieur
le Président mais revenons à nos moutons
et plus particulièrement à cette volonté
que l'on a
affirmé à travers notre amendement comme
celui du groupe socialiste de supprimer
cette restriction euh d'âge c'est-à-dire
la période entre le 1er janvier juillet
51 et le 31 décembre 55 inclus
et si nous avons proposé cet amendement
c'est que nous sommes
convaincus que les femmes seront
lourdement pénalisées et là on est au
cœur de la problématique c'est-à-dire
que les mesures proposées par le
gouvernement la majorité visent à faire
diversion de toute évidence mais la
réalité en disant notamment euh que le
gouvernement les femmes bénéficient de
nombreux dispositifs de solidarité au
sein des régimes de retraite qui
compenser efficacement les aléas de
carrière nous disons non nous disons que
le gouvernement ment comment peut-il
ignorer que la pension des femmes je
l'ai déjà dit est en moyenne égale à 62
% de celle des hommes qu'à la retraite
une femme sur de viit avec moins de 900
€ par mois c'est ça c'estàd c'estd le
minimum contributif les raisons sont
multiples la retraite et la caisse de
résonance je crois de toutes les
inégalités vécues par les femmes dans
leur vie active les bas salaires les
carrières morcelées incomplètes lié aux
interruptions pour élever les enfants la
multiplication des emplois précaires les
temps partiels imposés par les
entreprises sont Toutant d'inégalités
qui se cumulent au moment de la retraite
et les femmes ne sont pas je crois qu'il
faut le répéter ne sont pas seulement
touché par le niveau de leur pension
l'âge tardif auquel beaucoup d'entre
elles accèdent à la retraite témoignent
aussi de cette situation
inégalitaire pour ne pas subir la
décoote imposée et c'est ça un des
points à quoi conduit votre réforme qui
va accentuer toutes les inégalités et
bien faute d'avoir validé le nombre de
trimestre suffisant 30 % des femmes
seront contraintes sont contraintes
d'attendre 65 ans pour liquider leur
retraite compte 5 % des hommes souvent
d'ailleurs dans des conditions de vie
extrêmement précaire entre petit boulot
et chômage alors reculer et repousser à
67 ans et bien c'est rappeler aussi que
les précédentes réformes ont déjà
clairement dégradé le niveau de vie des
femmes retraitées
95 2003 2007 ce sont autant de bornes
qui ont vu une dégradation d'ailleurs
pour l'ensemble des Françaises et des
Français mais aussi pour les femmes le
projet de la droite va amplifier cette
détéioration et seul celles et ceux qui
auront les moyens pourront en se
tournant vers l'épargne privée se
garantir une rraite décente et en
remettant en cause la retraite à 60 ans
en allongeant la durée de cotisation en
refusant de reconnaître la pénibilité de
certaines professions et conditions de
travail le gouvernement a choisi la voie
de l'aggravation des inégalités femme
homme et du recul social pour tous et
pour
toutes madame Debray pour expliquer son
vote puis monsieur le ministre m'a
demandé intervenir qu'il peut faire à
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues depuis ce matin on a vraiment
l'impression que le sort des femmes
c'est la gauche qui les
détient je voudrais juste faire je
voudrais juste faire quelques rappels
historiques je ne vous ai jamais
interrompu je vous ai écouté depuis le
début je voudrais je vous ai écouté
depuis le début je ne vous ai jamais
interrompu je voudrais juste faire un
petit rappel historique en
1971 la loi Boulin il me semble que
c'était pas totalement ta gauche a créé
laamda l'opposition a voté contre en
1972 il y a eu la création de laavpf
l'assurance vieillesse de parents au
foyer là encore c'est la loi Boulin les
lois veill en 94 qui ont ouvert aux
parents de d'au moins de enfants
l'augmentation du toit de la pension de
reversion ça c'est encore une lo fil des
femmes là encore c'est la droite qui l'a
fait aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
90 % des femmes valident des trimestres
au titre de la MDA là encore c'est nous
qui l'avons fait en 2020 il y aura près
de 60 % des femmes qui auront validé des
trimestres au titre de la VPF
aujourd'hui on le sait la véritable
inégalité c'est l'égalité salariale
homm-femme
aujourd'hui qui a pris l'initiative d'un
projet de loi relatif à l'égalité
salarial entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est nous qui souhaite aujourd'hui et
qui veut favoriser l'accès des femmes
dans les conseils d'administration là
encore c'est nous donc monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je trouve que nous n'avons
aucune leçon à recevoir de la droite de
la gauche pardon nous devons travailler
ensemble et certainement pas
s'approprier vous n'avez pas le monopole
des femmes messieurs et mesdames de
gauche
merci Madame André peut-être le
ministre voà madame la Présidente et
puis ensuite le ministre va
répondre monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres mes chers
collègues je suis un peu étonné de la
tournure que prend ce débat les votes
ont eu lieu ils sont ce qu'ils sont nous
en prenons acte et nous diront mais pour
ce qui concerne l'égalité
hommes-femm nous avons demandé depuis
bien longtemps et et en permanence et
depuis la loi roui de 1982 et depuis les
la loi Génisson récente nous voyons bien
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'avance
pas dans ce domaine et ça n'est pas a
tour d'un article 31 qui va arriver dans
le débat de la loi de financeces qu'on
va régler la question de l'égalité
salariale et de l'égalité
professionnelle lorsque j'ai eu la
responsabilité de cette délégation
monsieur le président dans le ministre
en charge de ces questions s'était
engagé à remettre
sur l'action une grande loi avec des
vraies avancé trois ministres depuis je
vois bien qu'il y a des déclarations
d'intention mais il y a pas d'action
alors c'est vrai que plus on ne peut pas
régler un problème plus on en parle
certes mais aujourd'hui je vois monsieur
le ministre messieurs les ministres
qu'il faudrait une vraie volonté et
comment ne pas remarquer quelques
incohérences lorsque que à l'occasion de
la loi nom les collègues se battent pour
avoir une parité au conseil
d'administration au nom de l'égalité des
hommes et des femmes on leur dit non
c'est pas le moment au moment où dans
quelques jours nous allons voir arriver
ici la question de femmes dans les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises quand on demande que ça soit
aussi dans les établissements publics on
nous dit non les conseillers
territoriaux évidemment mais lorsqu'on
regarde les disposition actuelle pour
l'égalité des hommes et des femmes je
pense qu'il faut maintenant des actes
parce que les femmes elles n'y croient
plus elle n'y croit plus aux promesses
voilà et je prétends que dans ce
gouvernement et bien nous manquons de
volonté politique vous manquez messieurs
de volonté politique sur cette question
et Monsieur le Ministre ver vous êtes le
ministre en charge de l'égalité et des
droits des femmes voilà donc je vous
demande solennellement de bien y penser
en ce
moment merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le
Ministre oui merci monsieur le Président
le droit des femmes c'est aussi d'avoir
une retraite financée le droit des
femmes il y a les femmes et les hommes
qui ont leur retraite le droit des
femmes c'est d'avoir une retraite
financée il y a d'abord des Français
avir qu'il y ait des Français des
françaises il y a des Français d'une
manière générale et les Français d'une
manière générale ils ont droit à leur
retraite alors on peut toujours ne
jamais considérer que toute mesure est
une mesure de trop une mesure
inégalitaire mais au fond vous vous ne
proposez pas de réforme des retraites
vous proposez une réforme fiscale
proposer une réforme fiscale vous avez
une vision
électoraliste vraiment électoraliste
forcené de ce débat sur les retraites
vous essayez de vous adresser à chaque
public en disant regardez on fera mieux
on fera plus pour vous sauf qu'il y a 30
milliards d'euros de déficite qu'est-ce
qui va les payer les 30 milliards
d'euros de déficit c'est les retraité à
un moment donné c'est les jeunes de ce
pays on est bien obligé à un moment
donné de réformer ce système de
retraites si on veut que la répartition
elle fonctionne à plein tous les autres
pays l'ont fait on l'a déjà dit 10 fois
et on le redira c'est trop c'est trop
facile comme position et c'est trop
facile aussi de découvrir tout d'un coup
qu'il y a un problème avec les femmes
c'est le cas du parti socialiste vous
découvrez les
choses la retraite à 60 ans c'est une la
retraite à 60 ans la retraite à 60 ans
c'est une retraite qui a été faite pour
les hommes ça a été faite pour les
hommes vous n'avez jamais tenu compte
des femmes dans cette retraite à 60 ans
vous n'avez jamais lorsque vous étiez au
gouvernement vous êtes jamais posé la
question des 65 ans où est-ce que vous
êtes posé la question des 65 ans où
est-ce que Madame Aubri qui était
ministre d'affaires sociales s'est posé
la question des 65 ans il y a pas plus
d'injustice à 67 qu'à 65 où est-ce
qu'elle est où est la réponse du Parti
socialiste concrète la justice sociale
pour vous c'est juste un thème de
discours pour nous c'est un thème
d'action au quotidien et c'est ce que
nous faisons et nous le faisons et nous
vous le prouvons la VPF c'est cette
majorité qui l'a faite c'est pas le
Parti socialiste lors que nous prenons
des mesures pour réformer les retraite
c'est toujours cette majorité qui le
fait personne ne vous a obligé de ne
rien faire sur les femmes comme ça a été
le cas pendant des années de la part du
Parti socialiste alors c'est facile de
découvrir les choses et puis de mettre
son cœur en bandouillère et dire
regardez il faudrait nous simplement on
est confronté à une situation qui est
celle-ci sauvet-on ou pas le système par
répartition des retraites fait-on ou pas
dans le système par répartition des
retraites une place très importante au
système de solidarité qui est un système
de solidarité largement fait pour la
population féminine et heureusement et
on envoie les effets on envoie les
effets aujourd'hui lors que les femmes
qui sont nées dans les années 75 auront
15 trimestres de plus que les hommes
c'est bien grâce au système de
solidarité c'est pas autre chose vous ne
pouvez pas le nier ça c'est juste la
vérité et la réalité je voudrais dire
aussi que la décotte quelqu'un a parlé
de décotte je crois que c'est le
président ficher lors que il y a une
décotte la décote que vous avez fait
voter lorsque vous avez fait voter la
retraite à 6000 la réforme la décote
c'était 10 % par année c'est François
Fillon qui l'a ramené à 5 qui est-ce qui
payait les 10 % des côes c'était les
femmes c'était les femmes ça ne vous a
pas ému mais pas du tout vous avez vous
avez avoir été au gouvernement j'ai
jamais vu d'émotion du Parti socialiste
ou du Parti communiste sur la décotte à
10 % jamais jamais jamais jamais sauf
que là tout d'un coup vous le découvrez
vous auriez dû à ce moment-là voter la
réforme de 2003 il fallait voter la
réforme de François Fillon comme il
fallait voter la réforme de François
Fillon sur les carrières longues vous ne
l'avez pas fait non plus enfin Monsieur
S sur le fait de savoir si pour le fait
de savoir c'est qui paye vous dites
c'est 85 % ou 90 % les salariés d'abord
ce chiffre n'est pas tout à fait exact
pour la bonne raison que sur les 20
milliards d'euros de mesure d'âge il y a
une partie c'est-à-dire la moitié qui
sont financé par le fait de de repousser
le le solde des pensions le paiement des
pensions et l'autre moitié c'est sur les
cotisations les gens restent plus au
travail donc c'est cotisations mais sur
ces cotisations vous avez 6 milliards
donc sur les 10 vous avez 6 milliards
qui proviennent des employeurs qui
proviennent pas des des employés qui
proviennent des entreprises sur le swap
unéic il y a 3,3 milliards de
financement c'est 3,3 milliards de swap
unéic c'est les entreprisees sur les
mesures de recette les 4,7 milliards
d'euros c'est bien sur l'employeur et
sur les ménagés donc on a sur 30
milliards en dehors de l'effort de
l'État j'en conviens en dehors de
l'effort de l'État sur les 30 milliards
d'euros de financement vous avez 14
milliards d'euros qui proviennent des
entreprises ou des ménages aisés par
ailleurs je l'ai déjà dit et moi j'y
crois profondément dans un régime par
répartition Monsieur S c'est au fond
assez logique que ce soit ceux qui
travaillent qui cotisent au régime par
répartition on est dans un régime par
répartition on est pas dans un régime
par capitalisation on est dans un régime
par répartition répartition les actifs
payent les retraites des retraités c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne al on peut on
peut ne pas être d'accord avec ça mais
al dans ce CASL il faut dire on veut pas
de système par répartition on veut un
autre système et là on peut avoir un
débat mais si vous dites je suis très
attaché au régime par répartition alors
vous devez aussi être très attaché aux
modalités de financement du régime par
répartition
merci pas d'autre demande d'explication
de vote donc sur ces sous-amendement
1197 qui ont reçu l'avis défavorable de
la commission et du
gouvernement ceux qui sont favorables
son adoption le manifeste en levant la
main avis
contraire ne sont pas adoptés nous
passons à l'examen du sous-amendement
qui porte le numéro
1185 madame David pour explication de
vote ou merci monsieur le Président
cette ce
sous-amendement 1185 donc tendait à à
remplacer les mots trois enfants par un
enfant dans l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement il a reçu un avis
défavorable tant de la commission que du
gouvernement et vu le sort réservé à
l'amendement de Madame Panis nous nous
dirigeons donc vers le le l'adoption de
l'amendement du Gouvernement le 11
1182 qui va donc être adopté mais qui ne
prévoit pas le financement puisque cet
cet amendement renvoie son financement à
la future loi de
finances voilà donc sur ce que nous
disait monsieur le ministre et bien
justement qu'il y a besoin d'un
impératif financier que les femmes et
les hommes ont droit à une retraite
financée ça n'intéresse pas tellement
monsieur le ministre ancien ministre du
budget mais monsieur Tron est avec nous
donc je pense qu'il lui fera part de mes
propos puisqu'il nous annonce une mesure
qui coûterait 3,4 milliards d'euros
renvoyé donc à un financement ultérieur
au moment de la loi de finance et bien
monsieur le ministre je vous propose
pour ma part de de de nouveaux
financements et nous avions d'ailleurs
en ce sens monsieur le Président et nous
contestons encore le fait que nous nos
sous-amendements n''est pas été pris en
compte nos sous-amendements financiers
n'est pas été prise en compte sur
l'amendement du Gouvernement puisque
c'était des amendements qui permettaient
justement
voilanend gver nous en avionee une li
effectivement d'amendement financier et
celui que je vous propose là
était tend tendit à monter le taux
d'imposition à 33
% rappelle le règlement voilà poursuivez
madame David donc cette ce
sous-amendement que je vous proposais
aurait permis d'apporter des finances
nouvelles euh au gouvernement pour
pouvoir financer ces mesures en effet
avec cet amendement nous souhaitons
produire nous souhaaitions produire une
modification non négligeable de la
fiscalité des entreprises en mettant en
place un taux unique d'imposition des
plus-valu de cession d'actifs et là pour
le coup nous sommes bien dans un système
par répartition comme le disait à
l'instant monsieur le ministre puisque
nous demandons finalement à ce que
chacun paye sa part de l'impôt pour
pouvoir financer notre système de
protection sociale donc imposition des
plus-values de cession d'actifs qu'il
s'agisse de biens matériel brevet
éléments immatériels du patrimoine de
l'entreprise comme d'actif financiers
pur cette mesure serait une mesure
d'équité entre les entreprises
améliorant singulièrement la lisibilité
d'un dispositif qui au fil du temps
s'est très profondément technicisé qu'il
s'agisse en l'espèce de de jouer sur les
principes et dérogations de l'article
219 comme des autres dispositions
correctrices de l'impôt crédit d'impôt
divers entre autres ce serait aussi une
mesure de rendement puisque les
plus-values perçu par les entreprises ce
chiffre à plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'euros et qu'une progression
du moindre point de cette imposition est
donc génératrice de plusieurs centaines
de millions d'euros de recettes
nouvelles donc vous voyez des recette
nouvelle pour pouvoir financer ce que le
gouvernement veut mettre en place c'est
donc bien notre souci de sauvegarder
notre système de retraite par
répartition qui nous anime notons enfin
que la mesure que nous préconisons et
contre laquelle certains vont évidemment
s'élever au nom de la fameuse
concurrence fiscale internationale
monsieur Fourcade serait là il se il
s'élèverait à tous les coup c'est sûr
oubliant par la même aussi vite que
possible que les taux plus faibles le
pratiquer ailleurs ont souvent comme
origine des assiettes différentes de
l'imposition des résultats des
entreprises et une mesure de cohérence
avec celle que nous avons promu quant à
la fiscalité des plus-values des
particuliers il n'y a en effet aucune
raison que seul les particulier soi mis
à contribution pour renforcer les moyens
de financement des régimes de retraite
solidaires et qu'il est logique qu'un
effort particulier soit demandé aux
entreprises c'est donc bien le c'était
le sens de notre sous-amendement je ne
peux que regretter monsieur le Président
de nouveau que nous n'ayons pas pu
mettre en débat ces sous-amendements
puisque justement il est question de
financement d'équilibre financier
c'était aussi le souci de Monsieur le
Ministre de parler d'une recette d'une
retraite financée mais à aucun moment
vous ne voulez mettre en débat d'autres
propositions de financement nouveaux
vous le refusez systématiquement
catégoriquement nous y voyons là pour
notre part une volonté tout à fait
délibérée de faire faire peser 85 % voir
plus de cette réforme sur le dos des
travailleurs alors que les entreprises
le le et et la part de rémunération qui
a été déviée vers le capital n'est
absolument pas prise en compte dans ce
financement nous ne pouvons que le
regretter merci monsieur le Président
belle merci monsieur le
Président on a eu l'occasion de de de
dire les uns et les autres comment on
ressentait le débat ce matin madame
Debray je vais vous dire que le fait de
nous exprimer sur ces sujets ne signifie
pas pour nous que nous ayons une volonté
hégémonique d'en être les uniques
détenteurs simplement lorsque on a
examiner ces amendements et ce texte ici
au Sénat nous nous exprimons nous levons
le doigt et nous avons au Sénat la
possibilité de de défendre de défendre
nos amendements en même temps le le le
ministre qui qui vient de nous de nous
quitter qui va certainement revenir mais
monsieur Tron est là là euh ne peut pas
non plus dire n'importe quoi il peut pas
dire que les socialistes sont jusque-là
totalement indifférent au problème des
femmes ce que vient de dire la
présidente de la délégation des droits
des femmes je crois à pleinement
pleinement répondu et puis si vous
voulez vraiment que nous puissions
avoir une vraie évolution dans le débat
il faut pas nous renvoyer
systématiquement quelques affirmations
sur lesquelles nous sommes obligés de
répondre
vous vous nous dites assez régulièrement
vous n'avez rien à dire en face et euh
vous nous dites c'est soit nous ce que
nous nous proposons c'est-à-dire un
système par répartition soit autre chose
alors je veux rappeler moi ce matin
qu'une autre réforme est possible et que
légitimement vous devez vous aussi
prendre en considération peut-être
expertiser les propositions que nous
sommes amenés à faire mais pas nous dire
que nous n'avons aucune aucune
proposition à faire sur la réforme des
retraites j'ai conscience d'en avoir
déjà parlé puisque je l'ai fait à
l'occasion de la motion référendaire
mais permettez-moi de vous rappeler
quelques points qui pour nous sont
essentiels la réforme globale que nous
proposons sur les retraites elle
poursuit plusieurs objectifs notamment
celui de garantir le niveau de vie des
retraités parce que nous considérons et
nous l'avons dit que les réformes
antérieures ont conduit à une diminution
des retraites des des Françaises et des
Français aujourd'hui nous voulons une
réforme juste également qui permette des
efforts partagés alors qu'aujourd'hui
près de 90 % de l'effort repose sur les
seuls salariés nous voulons aussi une
réforme durable parce que nous
considérons que malgré la réforme que
vous allez faire adopter et bien dès
l'année prochaine à nouveau le problème
se reposera et nous voulons enfin
permettre davantage de choix individuels
dans le cadre de garantie collective
alors comment alors vous je je je
j'anticipe la la la question mais
comment vous faites pour P payer tout ça
alors je vous vous le redis premièrement
la mise à contribution de revenus du
capital comment par l'augmentation des
prélèvements sociaux sur les bon bonus
et stock option et c'est d'ailleurs ce
que propose la la Cour des comptes si
j'ai bien compris en le passant de 5 % à
38 %. par le relèvement du forfait
appliqué à l'intéressement et à la
participation en le passant de 4 à 20 %
par l'application de la CSG sur les
revenus du capital qui sont actuellement
exonéré et par la remise en cause de la
défiscalisation des plus-values sur les
sessions de filiales
nous
avons à partir de ce ce ce programme là
comptabilisé 19 milliards en 2010 et 25
milliards en 2025
ensuite 2è point par l'augmentation
modérée et étalée dans le temps des
cotisations patronales et salarial de
2012 à 2021 nous proposons une
augmentation de 0 0,1 point de
cotisation salariale et employeur chaque
année gain 12 milliards en
2025 3ème point on en a souvent parlé
Claude domezel s'est exprimé je crois
avec beaucoup de connaissance sur le
sujet le fond de réserve pour les
retraite pour faire face à toutes les
situations vous vous souvenez il a été
créé sous le gouvernement Jospin et il
avait pour vocation de sécuriser les
jeunes générations d'actifs et de
compenser leur effort depuis 2002
malheureusement il n'a pas été alimenté
nous voulons l'alimenter de manière
régulière par la création d'une surtaxe
de 15 % de l'impôt sur les sociétés à
quitté par les banques 3 milliards
d'euros par an avec un rendement de 4 %
voilà pour les ressources je pourrait
parler de l'emploi des seniors qui est
essentiel puisque la question elle est
aussi posée lorsque un senior de plus de
55 ans sur 3 est aujourd'hui en activité
le trisème pilier de notre réforme c'est
la prise en compte de la pénibilité la
prise en compte de la pénibilité doit
être une priorité et toute période de
travail pénible doit bénéficier d'une
majoration des annuïtés permettant de
partir plutôt à la retraite et vous
savez que nous proposons mais comme
d'autres hein j'ai entendu des leaders
syndicaux notamment évoquer ce sujet la
retraite choisie c'est-à-dire un système
universel et personnalisé qui
permettrait de davantage de choix
individuels et en même temps qui
permettrait de garantir les retraites
alors voilà pardon de vous avoir répété
ces choses mais ne dites plus que votre
réforme est la seule et qu'elle est
inéluctable d'autres peuvent avoir
d'autres propositions peut-être
légèrement différentes ou différentes
nous avons un projet de réforme des
retraites et nous sommes bien bien
décidés à le proposer aux Français et
peut-être à le mettre en œuvre très
rapidement monsieur carer pourrait
expliquer son
vote
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre oui nous avons notre projet de
retraite et il y en a
d'autres j'ai déjà dit au ministre en
son temps écoutez monsieur le ministre
même si nous ne partageons absolument
pas vos orientations nous considérons
que vous avez un projet voilà le nôtre
considérer qu'il y a donc un projet
alternatif et lorsque vous nous dites
d'un revers de main circuler il n'y a
rien à voir le seul possible c'est le
nôtre parce qu'il est financé parce que
il maintient le système par répartition
ben écoutez monsieur le ministre c'est
faux tout ça est faux il ne peut pas
maintenir le système par répartition
parce que le projet que vous nous
proposez n'est pas financé n'étant pas
financé il portera un coup au système
par répartition vous ne faites écoutez
on l'a bien
compris on ne vous le reproche pas vous
en avez le droit mais on le dénonce que
dans la com et chaque fois que vous
prenez la parole c'est-elle le torero
averti vous prenez ce petit chiffon
rouge pour essayer de nous faire foncer
sur des arguments fallacieux à l'endroit
des socialistes ou à l'endroit de C ou
de là et je trouve d'ailleurs que
quelquefois moi le premier
he on y va alors que on a bien tort non
écoutez vous semblez par contre inquiet
de ce qui peut se passer demain et de ce
qui pourrait se passer ultérieurement et
là moi je je partage je veux dire on
sait pas comment peut dégénérer un
mouvement que vous aurez déclenché de
cette nature mais moi je sais comment on
pourrait l'arrêter pas par des petites
manœuvres au Sénat monsieur le Président
où on déclare l'urgence sur tel ou tel
article pour essayer d'influencer
l'opinion par derrière c'est-à-dire
qu'on utilise des basses manœuvres
pardonnez-moi le terme pour ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler des grandes causes non
est-ce que c'est très digne d'une grande
démocratie comme la nôtre je n'en suis
pas sûr mais je vais vous la donner la
clé commençons monsieur le ministre à
trouver un accord sur le fait de dire on
renonce à systématiser et à bloquer tout
ce projet sur des questions d'âge de
départ et on travaille sur des durées de
cotisation et là vous allez voir les
organisations syndicales sont capables
certainement de vous entendre et de
revenir à une table des négociations qui
d'ailleurs a été peu fréquenté pendant
la période donc ne me faites pas croire
que vous n'auriez pas compris qu'il y a
une forme
d'inéluctabilité à la mobilisation
syndicale que ces pauvres gens qui vont
faire des grèves reconductibles seraient
irresponsabl qui feraiit courir le
risque au pays après une crise au moment
où ça redémarre de le bloquer oh là là
oh là là qu'est-ce qui se passe non
c'est vous les responsables c'est vous
pour des raisons idéologiques parce que
le président veut une victoire
idéologique il y a pas d'autre raison
c'est celle-là et si vraiment vous
voulez vous placer sur le terrain de la
démocratie sur le terrain social on peut
ouvrir immédiatement un Grenel de la
retraite dans notre pays qui aurait pour
motif ou pour de départ une négociation
sur la durée des cotisations alors on
sait très bien que vous allez
recommencer avec le chiffon rouge et les
socialistes et les socialistes vous
savez à force de parler des socialistes
monsieur le ministre vous nous faites
une pub extraordinaire continuez moi
vous savez à votre place moi moi vous
m'entendez pas souvent parler de votre
mouvement je sais d'ailleurs même pas
comment il s'appelle vous changez
tellement souvent que bon je je je ne me
le rappelle plus mais mais continuez et
puis qui croirait dans ce pays monsieur
le ministre
ver que vous détenez la vérité que tout
ce que vous dites est exact vous croyez
Monsieur le Ministre que lorsque vous
parlez de l'absence de projet alternatif
des socialistes c'est bien ce que vous
faites franchement moi je croyais que
que vous aviez donné une autre image et
que vous pouviez débattre projet contre
projet plutôt que de nier la réalité
c'est quand même pas grandir une
démocratie comme la nôtre que de feindre
de d'ignorer le projet alternatif et d'
absolument pas vouloir en discuter avec
les opposants qui représente Bonard
Malan et puis je vais dire une dernière
chose ce pantomime que vous nous faites
à tous les coups quand vous êtes enulé
avec ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler le
centre est dramatique déplorable et moi
je pense que notre démocratie mérite
bien mieux donc allons sur le terrain de
la durée des cotisations et vous verrez
la sérénité reviendra dans notre pays
merci
bien monsieur ser pour expliquer son
vote merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je voulais revenir sur les
propos de Monsieur le Ministre qui a
déployé deux arguments en réponse à ce
que nous avions pu
exposer vous nous dites que qu' n'est
pas exact de dire comme nous le faisons
qu'il y a une très grande disproportion
entre ce qui provient des salarié dans
le financement de la réforme et ce qui
provient du capital de la rente ou de la
spéculation vous nous dites que c'est
inexa parce que il y a les cotisations
des entreprises mais Monsieur le
Ministre les cotisations des entreprises
ce sont les cotisations du monde du
travail ce sont les cotisations qui
proviennent du travail des salariés et
ces cotisations il est clair qu'ell se
répartissent en deux parts l'une est
payée par le salarié et l'autre part est
payée par
l'entreprise mais vous nous dites ce
n'est pas exact parce qu'il y a
finalement ce qui est payé par
l'entreprise d'un
côté ce qui est payé par le salarié d'un
côté excusez-moi et ce qui est payé de
l'autre côté par l'entreprise le capital
la rente et la spéculation mais quelle
conception avez-vous de l'entreprise
nous ne sommes pas du tout d'accord ce
que nous disons c'est que pour 90 % ce
sont les revenus du travail qu'il soit
payé par le salarié ou par l'employeur
tout le monde comprend cela et le reste
c'est ce qui est payé par le capital la
rente et la spéculation voilà premier
point donc vous ne pouvez pas dire que
ce qui est payé par l'entreprise ce sont
les revenus du capital quelle conception
de l'entreprise
d'ailleurs
deuxièmement vous nous dites puisque
c'est un régime par
répartition alors la totalité du
financement doit revenir doit doit
provenir des revenus du travail mais en
même temps que vous dites cela vous
faites le contraire puisque dans votre
réforme il y a bien une partie du
financement qui ne provient pas des
revenus du travail qu'il soit les reven
payé par les salariés ou les revenus
payés par l'entreprise simplement ce que
nous disons c'est que cette partie elle
est trop petite elle est trop restreinte
alors vous nous dites il y a un
postulat à partir du moment où c'est une
une retraite par
répartition il ne faut pas faire appel à
d'autres revenus que ceux du travail
mais pourquoi d'où vient ce postulat
comment est-il fondé c'est une
déclaration a priori et vous savez très
bien que c'est faux puisque vous faites
le contraire mais vous faites trop peu
le contraire monsieur le ministre voilà
le problème alors nous nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec ces syllogismes et ces
fausses évidences nous considérons qu'il
faut bien sûr maintenir la retraite par
répartition nous y tenons très fort mais
pour financer la retraite par
répartition il faut faire appel à tous
les revenus y compris les revenus du
capital de la rente et de la spéculation
voilà ce que nous disons et quand vous
nous expliquez que dès lors que
l'on dit qu'il faut faire appel à ces
derniers revenus alors nous serions pour
la retraite par
capitalisation j'espère que tout le
monde comprend combien ce raisonnement
est faux monsieur le ministre je pense
que vous l'aurez compris vous-même c'est
pourquoi j'arrête là mon intervention
merci madame la Présidente
ni cat pour expliquer le vote merci
monsieur le Président alors écoutez moi
je viens de voir que Madame Pariso s'est
exprimé dans le débat ce matin voilà et
euh on sait très bien que ça compte
énormément puisque elle nous explique le
le film alors d'abord elle dit bien
entendu à la veille d'une journée
d'action que c'est très préjudiciable et
que ça participe à une dégradation de la
réputation française alors voyez où est
la réputation française elle est quand
les salariés la population critique le
gouvernement ça nuit à la réputation
française et alors ensuite elle dit
cette réforme est le fruit d'une très
grande concertation et de beaucoup de
compromis alors là on a compris tout de
suite c'est un compromis avec le
patronat puisque il veut la retraite par
capitalisation alors comme le
gouvernement n' pas
tout de suite dire qu'il veut aller vers
la retraite par capitalisation il fait
un compromis avec Madame Pariso puisque
dans son petit livre Bible elle disait
retraite par capitalisation donc
beaucoup de compromis et ensuite elle
donne
évidemment un satisfait cite à Monsieur
le Ministre vert puisqu'elle dit le fait
majeur qui explique le déficit du
système par répartition c'est
l'évolution de la démographie ce qui
nous répète sans discontinuer depuis
maintenant une semaine alors écoutez moi
je je dis comme d'autres
franchement disons les choses clairement
vous voulez faire payer au salariés 85 à
90 % des retraites de cette réforme
voilà du capital on n parle pas c'est un
gros mot pour vous on l'a bien compris
mais voyez-vous comme les choses ont
beaucoup changé depuis 1945 vous n'avez
cesse de nous le répéter moi je vous
répète encore une fois que ce qui a
beaucoup changé c'est que le capital
financier a envahi le paysage économique
c'est-à-dire l'argent pour
l'argent déconnecté des réalités
économiques et bien entendu sociales on
voit ce qu'il en coûte au salariés
puisque il paye la crise du capitalisme
financier et bien vous voulez qui leur
en coûte encore plus et qui payent en
plus maintenant encore plus pour leur
retraite alors voyez on pourrait
effectivement avoir un débat un vrai
débat c'est-à-dire si nous sommes tous
d'accord pour la retraite par
répartition puisque vous n'avz de cesse
de le répéter discutons du financement
de la retraite par répartition discutons
de qui doit payer quelle part doivent
payer les uns et les autres ça c'est une
discussion int dig de parlementaire et
non pas de répéter sans cesse ce que
nous dit Laurence
Paris bien monsieur
Dallier pour expliquer son
vote veillur le président monsieur le
ministre très rapidement jeis dire
effectivement à Madame borve que oui ça
on est d'accord avec elle depuis 1945 le
monde a changé et l'idéologie sur
laquelle elle s'appuie depuis des années
s effondré et le mod qu'elle défendait
c'est
également c'est également écoutez madame
je ne prendrai pas de leçon sur une
époque où effectivement dans cette
enceinte et sous l'git du général de
Gaulle on a fait de grandes choses mais
ça n'est pas encore une fois la seule
gauche qui a fait avancer la France dans
le domaine social vous devriez vous en
rappeler ceci étant dit je voulais
prendre la parole pour souligner un
point intéressant dans ce débat suite à
l'intervention du président
il semble qu'effectivement on soit un
tournant puisque tout le monde a l'air
d'accord dans cet hémicycle pour
considérer qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui
une réforme alors effectivement on n'est
pas d' mais écoutez en tous les cas moi
c'est ce que j'ai retenu de ce qu'a dit
le président belle nous sommes d'accord
les uns et les autres pour considérer
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui une réforme
parce que le système par répartition est
en danger effectivement nous divergeons
sur la manière nous nous considérons
qu'il faut effectivement toucher à l'âge
et trouver des financements complé
mais mon cher collègue lorsque vous nous
dites que notre réforme n'est pas
financi est déséquilibrée à objectif
2018 elle est équilibré on sait
qu'effectivement et bien
écoutez laissez-moi terminer laissez-moi
terminer à objectif 2018 elle est
équilibrée et d'ici là nous savons qu'il
faut trouver 60 milliards vous vous
dites aujourd'hui au français on ne
touche pas au mesures d'âge et nous
pvons trouver les financements par
ailleurs mais je n'ai pas le sentiment
aujourd'hui que dans l'opinion publique
tout le monde est bien compris cela et
c'est là où vous pourriez peut-être
faire uvre de pédagogie parce que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens pensent
encore suite au débat tels qu'ils
ressortent de ces enceintes
qu'eectivement il y a d'un côté le
gouvernement qui dit il faut faire
quelque chose et de l'autre ceux qui
disent nous pouvons ne toucher à rien
donc je trouve que le débat avance
j'aimerais effectivement que de bonne
volonté les uns ou les autres nous ons
un peu plus à faire comprendre à nos
concitoyens qu'il faut effectivement
faire une
réforme monsieur le ministre vou ajouter
quelque chose avant que nous passions au
vote oui je voulais juste monsieur le
Président dire que on est d'accord pour
que il y ait un débat sur le financement
il y aura un débat d'ailleurs en PLF et
PLFSS sur le sur le financement et nous
avons apporté des financements nouveaux
nous avons apporté à peu près 4
milliards d'euros de financement 4,2
milliards d'euros de financement avec
les mesures nouvelles que nous avons
prises donc il y a bien des mesures de
financement mais il faut faut aussi des
mesures d'augmentation de l'âge légal de
la retraite quoi que vous disiez on est
bien lors que on veut modifier
changer faire évoluer un système de
retraite parce que le système de
retraite ne fonctionne plus comme c'est
le cas dans plein d'autres pays il faut
aussi à un moment donné avoir un peu de
courage juste un peu de courage parce
que l'opinion publique c'est sûr hein
elle préfère qu'on touche pas à l'âge de
la retraite ça c'est vrai mais en même
temps l'intérêt des Français c'est qu'à
un moment donné on augmente d'une façon
responsable et raisonnable l'âge de la
retraite les autres autes pays l'ont
fait et donc nous devons le faire faut
juste un peu de courage juste juste
juste c'est c'est alors c'est sûr que
c'est pas partagé sur tous les rangs
hein ici mais nous avons le courage de
le faire même si c'est difficile moi
j'ai bien apprécié sur ce qu'a dit
Monsieur sur sur les travailleurs et
l'entreprise mais c'est une évolution là
idéologique parce que quand on entend
autant taper sur ces bancs ici sur
l'entreprise on est tout d'un coup un
peu étonné de dire les travailleurs et
l'entreprise c'est la même chose moi je
suis assez d'accord les gens qui
travaillent dans les entreprises et les
entrepreneurs c'est un peu la même chose
s'il y a plus d'entreprise il y a plus
d'emploi bon c'est aussi simple que ça
et diaboliser comme vous le faites
systématiquement les entreprises
considérez que dans l'économie
l'entreprise c'est le diable c'est
vraiment l'horreur absolue c'est pas
tout à fait comme ça qu'on voit les
choses nous on pense que évidemment les
bonnes entreprises font les beaux
emplois et c'est donc une évolution
idéologique mais jusqu'à présent vous ne
nous avez pas dit dans le financement
que font que fait le monde du travail
entreprise et salariés vous nous avez
toujours dit il y a 85 % qui sont qui
sont supportés par les travailleurs par
les salariés pour être exact c'était le
terme que vous citiez et ce terme je
vous ai dit que ce n'était pas exact que
c'est pas exact que beaucoup des mesures
sont supportées par les ménages zisés au
travers des revenus du capital que
beaucoup de mesures sont supportées par
les entreprises elles-mêmes et pas par
les salariés j'ai essayé de vous dire
que les salariés dans un régime par
répartition les salariés au sens large
du terme les les commerçants les
artisans les salariés eux-mêmes sont
évidemment au cœur du financement d'un
régime par répartition il faut bien
l'admettre il a été créé comme ça et
c'est probablement sa force nous
appelons de la fiscalité nouvelle pour
financer des mesures supplémentaires
dans le domaine de la solidarité c'est
les 30 milliards de solidarité dont je
parlais la répartition ce n'est pas la
fiscalisation merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons maintenant procéder au vote
sur ce
sousamendement5 ceux qui sont à son
adoption le manifeste en levant la
main avis
contraire n'est pas
adopté l'amendement
1186 qui
le explique son vote monsieur le
Président ficher B oui mais là c'est
pareil nous voulions présenter le
sous-amendement monsieur le Président et
oui c'est sous-amendement euh
1186 certes la Commission a mis un avis
défavorable et puis le gouvernement
aussi mais c'est l'impossibilité pour
nous d'expliciter nos propositions
financières nous y reviendrons très
régulièrement car de aujourd'hui et bien
le problème du financement qui est au
cœur du débat on vient de le voir montre
bien que la réalité est totalement
différente de ce que dit le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que le problème est un
problème bon de faire supporter au plus
grand nombre c'est-à-dire aux retraités
aux salariés aux chôeurs aux femmes qui
sont en des difficultés grandissante et
bien cette réforme alors ce n'est pas
d'hier d'ailleurs pour revenir sur des
problèmes de fiscalité nationale hein
qui a été utilisé que la fiscalité a été
utilisée pour financer les régimes de
retraite et sans vouloir rappeler à nos
collègues de la majorité sénatoriale
qu'ils seront amenés très prochainement
à débattre et sans doute ou presque à
soutenir en projet de budget concernant
des mesures d'augmentation des impôts
destinées à financer en partie la
réforme des retraites on peut en effet
remonter dans le temps et se rendre
compte de cette antériorité de la
fiscalisation des prestations sociales
vous venez de dire moi je suis pas pour
la fiscalisation non euh on y va aussi
une fois constaté la nonadhésion par
exemple des agriculteurs au régime
général des salariés pour la sécurité
sociale il a bien fallu autre chose et
le fait que le principal outil qui fut
utilisé pour alimenter le régime
agricole fut celui de la fiscalité une
fiscalité dédiée d'une part et une part
grandissante soit dit en passant au fil
de la chute continue de la part du
financement du régime supporté par les
agriculteurs eux-mêmes et une fiscalité
indirectement attribuée au même régime
par versement d'une subvention
d'équilibre tiré du budget du ministère
de l'Agriculture alors il arrive il
arriva même pour ceux qui ont quelques
années de mandat parlementaire et ils
sont relativement nombreux ici que l'on
vota des budget de l'agriculture ou la
subvention au budget annexe des
prestations sociales agricoles
devenu depuis le fipsa était le premier
poste des crédits du ministère et où le
BAPSA lui-même obéissait à des règles de
3/ ti3 alors ceci pour dire que un/3 de
subvention d'équilibre 1/3 de fiscalité
dédiée et le reste entre concours de la
compensation
interrégime et contribution propre des
assurés eux-mêmes ce sont autant et bien
de manifestation du régime général à la
solidarité notamment pour les les
agriculteurs
alors on pourrait revenir aussi sur
l'ISF c'est-à-dire là
aussi agir sur l'élément qui les plus
dynamiques des bases fiscal existant
dans notre pays le patrimoine des plus
riches dont le nombre ne cesse
d'augmenter et dont la richesse de cesse
de croîre crise financière ou pas parce
que c'est là où ce que l'on a constaté
et on aura certainement l'occasion d'y
revenir c'est que l'accroissement des
inégalités en terme de répartition de la
richesse et bien c'est le corps de notre
préoccupation dans cette réforme et il
est là le problème c'est-à-dire que en
fait nous avons un enjeu politique à
relever celui du financement péren et
durable des retraites et cet enjeu
s'accompagne d'un défi de court terme
que nous devons relever sous peine
devoir mettre en péril notre régime de
retraite solidaire celui du déficit de
trésorerie cert et puis après il y a
tout le problème qui est intimement lié
au problème des retraites c'est les bas
salaires et le chômage qui là aussi ne
font pas que des malheureux et on voit
bien que cela nourrit la rémunération du
capital et favorise le gonflement du
patrimoine donc il est donc légitime que
l'on augmente l'ISF dont la base
constitue une image imparfaite et quand
la majorité laisse penser que l'on ira à
la suppression du bouclier fiscal à
condition que l'on euh supprime l'ISF là
aussi il y aura des débats très
intéressants que nous ne manquerons pas
auquels nous ne manquerons pas de
participer voilà ce que je voulais dire
monsieur le Président merci explication
de vote monsieur sur
monsieur le le président monsieur le
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues je pense que le journal
Libération a eu raison de titrer ce
matin les bobars faussent le débat parce
que Monsieur le le ministre je veux très
très rapidement relever votre dernière
intervention parce que vous nous avez
dit s'agissant du groupe socialiste ah
je suis très étonné parce que j'avais
compris finalement que vous étiez contre
l'entreprise vous avez tellement parler
contre l'entreprise enfin monsieur le
ministre nous sommes pour l'entreprise
nous sommes qui pour qu'il ait plus
d'entreprise dans ce pays et ça fait des
décennies que nous disons cela et nous
voulons même que davantage de nos
concitoyens puissent créer des
entreprises les développer les faire
prospérer pour qu'elles exportent et
pour que l'on lutte contre la
désindustrialisation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui alors écoutez
merci de ne pas nous renvoyer des
caricatures complètement archaïques qui
n'ont strictement aucun rapport avec ce
que nous pensons et à ce que notre parti
en particulier développe depuis très
longtemps vous le savez très bien donc
cela ne grandit absolument pas le débat
et nous vous redisons que quand les
entreprises pai des cotisations pour la
sécurité sociale ou pour les retraites
et bien ces cotisations
elles les paient avec le fruit du
travail de tous ceux qui travaillent
dans ces entreprises c'est donc la
contribution du travail du monde du
travail au financement et il n'est pas
besoin de nous renvoyer des caricatures
auxquelles nous n'avons jamais cru moi
je n'ai jamais cru je suis en total
désaccord avec ceux qui sont contre
l'entreprise nous voulons beaucoup
d'entreprises nous voulons que les
entreprises fonctionnent autrement que
les revenus soi est parti autrement nous
voulons une autre politique industrielle
certes nous voulons que les droits de
chacune et de chacun soient respectés
dans l'entreprise certes et nous l'avons
montré mais nous sommes pour
l'entreprise et merci de ne pas nous
renvoyer ces
arcaes pas d'autres demande
d'explication de vote je vais donc
soumettre ceux qui sont favorables à cet
amendement ce sous-amendement 186 qui a
un double avis défavorable le manifeste
en levant la
main avis contraire
n pas
adopté alors nous passons maintenant
sous amendement
1198 madame BRI pour explication de
vote chers collègues de la majorité si
vous prenez la peine de lire cet
amendement vous verrez non non un ou
plusieurs enfants vous verrez que c'est
un amendement de
compromis de repli certainement mais de
compromis entre votre
proposition et la nôtre donc ne venez
pas parler d'obstruction mais je n'ai
pas l'impression je n'ai pas
l'impression que
euh cela cela vous convain mais puisque
nous poursuivons le débat euh monsieur
le ministre si vraiment vous aviez voulu
comme vous le prétendez sauver le
système par répartition il eut fallu
l'annoncer dès le programme du candidat
président et une fois élu parce que le
sujet était d'importance reconnaissez-le
et une fois élu lancer une grande
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
et à la fin du cycle des négociations la
loi eu sanctionné ou positivement ou ou
négativement cette cette négociation ce
n'est pas le choix que vous avez fait et
par ailleurs vous avez trop souvent mis
en avant les déficits causés par la
crise financière et économique pour
faire cette loi vous l'avez trop souvent
dit donc pour que on vous croit sur la
l'explication que vous donné d'être le
sauveur du système
par répartition et puis alors quant à
l'argument rabâé qui tient d'après vous
à l'absence de projet du Parti
socialiste il n'est pire sour que celui
qui ne veut pas entendre on vient encore
le président belle vient encore de vous
faire en accélérer l'exposé du projet
que nous avons alors ce qui été
intéressant c'est que vous le critiquiez
c'est que vous disiez à tel ou tel
passage ça ne va pas comme nous nous
faisons du vôtre quand nous vous disons
vous savez très bien qu'il n'est pas
durable puisqueil y a déjà une un
nouveau rendez-vous et qu'en plus il
n'est pas financé totalement alors il y
a un autre argument que vous utilisez
monsieur le ministre depuis une semaine
qui consiste à dire en Superman de la de
la
répartition que finalement par
irresponsabilité la gauche ne voudrait
pas sauver le système par répartition
vous aurez beaucoup de mal vous aurez
beaucoup de mal monsieur le Président à
bout à en convaincre l'opinion si j'ai
bien entendu ce qu'elle réclame quand
elle est dans la rue ou quand elle n'y
est pas quand elle est au travail mais
vous aurez d'autant plus de mal que je
voudrais vous faire un petit rappel
historique ça voudrait dire donc que
finalement la gauche est pour la
retraite par capitalisation c'est ça si
on n'est pas par pour la répartition est
au bout all est au bout mais je voudrais
vous rappeler quand même que un des
premiers gestes législatifs du
gouvernement Jospin ça a été d'abroger
la loi Tomas qui introduisait les fonds
de pension en France alors là vous aurez
quand même du mal à faire croire à
l'opinion que la gauche serait pour la
retraite par capitalisation non monsieur
le ministre vous n'êtes pas le sauveur
de la retraite par répartition ce n'est
pas
vrai bien
pas d'autre demande d'explication de
vote je
soumets je soumets ceux qui sont
favorables à l'adoption de manifeste en
levant la main avis
contraire si vous voulez bien il n'est
pas
adopté un sousamendement numéro
1187 madame
David oui merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement donc reçu deux avis
défavorables mais j'aimerais profiter de
cette explication
pour pour donner un à nouveau
connaissance à notre Haute Assemblée
d'une de nos propositions contenu dans
notre proposition de loi pour financer
justement par répartition notre système
de retraite par répartition hein et
effectivement monsieur le ministre nous
disait il y a un instant que le
financement pour un système par
répartition ce sont les cotisations
sociales et bien justement dans notre
proposition de de loi nous avons des
propositions pour euh les cotisations de
notre système de santé notamment pour
faire pour ex pour supprimer pardon les
exonérations qui sont aujourd'hui euh en
faveur des entreprises et et qui coûte
quand même à l'état environ à l'état et
donc à notre protection sociale environ
30 milliards d'euros donc par un nouvel
sous-amendement nous souhaaitions euh
cette fois-ci faire un un lien étroit
entre la relation du travail et plus
plus précisément ces modes d'exécution
et les retraites car en effet si la
sécurité sociale connaît aujourd'hui un
déficit de cotisation c'est bien quand
même de par la faute de votre politique
systématique d'exonération et en raison
d'un manque criant de de cotisant vous
nous parlez sans arrêt monsieur le
ministre d'un problème démographique
peut-être un problème démographique mais
surtout le problème de notre de notre
système de protection sociale c'est bien
un déficit de salariés puisque de plus
en plus d'entreprises délocalisent et
vont faire fabriquer à l'étranger ce qui
est ensuite ramené dans notre pays et
d'autre part de du fait des de la
politique
d'exonération que vous mettez en place
donc c'est bien d'un déficit de salariés
qui avec leurs employeurs cotiseraiit et
financerait notre régime de retraite
au-delà même de toute au-delà même donc
toute notre protection sociale mais vos
majorités successives hein pour
satisfaire le mdeef et bien exige
toujours plus de flexibilité nonont eu
de cesse d'amoindrir les protections
collectives faciliter les licenciements
les recours aux contrats atpiques dans
certaines entreprises ou certains
secteurs d'activité sont devenus en
réalité la norme c'était là le sens de
cet amendement puisque de ce
sous-amendement puisque nous souhaitions
et bien appliquer une majoration de
cotisation sociale de 10 % sur
l'ensemble de la masse salariale des
entreprises qui employaient de manière
excessive des salariés temporaires que
ce soit CDI euh CDD pardon ou contrat
intérimaire donc monsieur le ministre
vous nous disiez aussi que nous avions
une drôle de vision de de l'entreprise
alors évidemment évidemment nous
souhaitons que les entreprises
participent à hauteur de ce qu'elles
gagnent à notre protection sociale parce
que en vérité quand même vous vous nous
dites que c'est pas vrai mais euh la la
la part rémunération du travail
c'est-à-dire cotisation et salaire a
quand même été spolié hein d'une grande
partie de de de ces revenus pour aller
alimenter les revenus financiers hein
pas loin de 10 % ça a été dit depuis le
début de de ce débat donc monsieur le
ministre nous nous sommes bien
conscients qu'il y a besoin nous sommes
bien conscients qu'il y a besoin
d'entreprise dans notre pays sans
entreprise il n'y a pas d'emploi mais
sans salariés et bien les entreprises ne
feraient pas non plus autant de Bénéfic
que ce qu'elles font et ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut reprocher à nos
entreprises quand même c'est leur manque
de responsabilité sociale hein un grand
sujet dont un de vos prédécesseurs
Xavier Bertrand nous avait fait 1000
éloges et nous avait promis là encore un
texte un texte législatif qui imposerait
du coup aux entreprises d'avoir une
certaine responsabilité sociale et pas
seulement d'un point de vue
environnemental puisqueaujourd'hui je le
sais il y a des conventions qui existent
il y a des runion qui se mett en œuvre
de par un peu partout dans le monde
d'ailleurs où les entreprises se
glorifient de leur responsabilité social
d'un point de vue de l'environnement et
bien j'aimerais qu'il metent autant que
ces entreprises mettent autant d'ardeur
et et d'envie pour avoir une autre
responsabilité sociale qui est la leure
celle des salariés qui sont salariés
dans leur entreprise et qui sont bien
souvent souspayé mal reconnu et quand on
voit la l'évolution des conditions de
travail monsieur le ministre et pour
avoir parti parciper à la mission
maettre je peux vous garantir qu'on a
entendu des choses assez dramatiques sur
l'évolution des conditions de travail
dans nos entreprises et bien je pense
que la responsabilité sociale devrait
faire l'objet d'un d'un accord pourquoi
pas un accord inter national
interprofessionnel qui pourrait se
décliner dans un projet de loi et qui
permettrait à ce que ce genre de
situation et bien tend à se à diminuer
plutôt qu'à augmenter d'un point de vue
de des conditions de vie des salariés
dans notre entreprise donc voilà nous
avions de nouveau un sous-amendement qui
permettait d'apporter des recettes
nouvelles dans notre système de retraite
par répartition malheureusement là
encore nous n'avons pas pu en débattre
nous n'avons pas pu faire valoir ces
arguments je ne peux que le regretter et
et vous inviter mes chers collègues à
prendre connaissance de notre
proposition de loi qui garantit le
financement du droit à la retraite à 60
ans si pas d'autre demande je vais
maintenant faire céder au vote sur cette
sous-amendement ceux qui sont favorables
le manifeste en levant la main avis
contraire n'est pas adopté et nous
passons à l'examen de du sous-amendement
1190 explication de vente madame la
Présidente Nicole
borv merci monsieur le Président alors
encore une annonce qui va évidemment
faire de ne pas réjouir les parleement
aire je suppose puisque Monsieur Gérard
Longuet président du groupe UMP a
déclaré qu'il ne voyait pour l'instant
plus de marge de manœuvre du Parlement
c'est-à-dire mes chers collègues là
vraiment nous ne servons à rien donc ce
qu'on comprend c'est que bon en fonction
de on ne sait pas quoi peut-être le
président de la République lui dira
quelque chose et que vous attendez sans
doute vous vous attendez qu'il vous dise
quelque chose mais donc les
parlementaires vous ne servez à rien
enfin en tout cas les parlementaires de
la majorité parce que Monsieur Longuet
ne peut pas empêcher l'opposition de
mener un débat parlementaire voilà alors
dans le débat parlementaire je vous
propose notre
sous-amendement notre sous-amendement
qui est bien du ressort des
parlementaires excusez-moi qui est
d'interdire la pratique aujourd'hui
répandu à savoir l'attribution de stock
option cette pratique qui permet en
réalité aux entreprises de gratifier
parfois de manière très importante leurs
principaux dirigeants constitue une
méthode de
contournement pure et simple de la
législation sociale intégré dans les
salaires il serait soumis à cotisation
sociale et rapporterait selon la Cour
des comptes plusieurs milliards d'euros
car revenons-en aux sources qu'est-ce
qu'un stock une stock option c'est la
possibilité accordée à une minorité de
personnes d'acheter une action à un prix
donné quel que soit son cours exemple un
PDG bénéficie de stock option à 20 €
l'une si le cours de l'action est de 50
il peut exercer son option c'est-à-dire
bénéficier d'action au prix de 20 et
empêcher empocher pardon une plus-value
de 30 certes la législation sociale a
depuis 3 ans évolué mais ces éléments de
rémunération continue à se voir
appliquer un taux de cotisation
différent de ce appliquer sur les
salaire donc vous voyez là on n pas dans
la dans la fiscalisation et autres on
est dans la réalité c'est-à-dire que on
détourne des salaires par d'autres pour
éviter les cotisations sociales sous des
autres formes de
rémunération voilà c'est la
défiscalisation merci défiscalisation
pour les amis et cotisation pour les
salariés et cela ne change rien
c'està-dire la toxicité de cette
pratique sur l'économie car le
bénéficiaire a alors tout loisir de
revendre par la suite parfois dans la
même journée les actions qu'il a acheté
à villeprix bien plus cher qu'il ne les
a lui-même acheté ça voilà la bulle
financière vous voyez déconnecté de la
réalité économique ben ça en fait partie
vous le savez bien évidemment puisque
vous l'avez voté cette pratique
pervertit la relation entre les
dirigeants et les entreprises les PDG
portant moins d'intérêt pour leur
entreprise à long terme que pour leurs
propres intérêts particuliers à court
terme voilà donc ça ça nuit à
l'entreprise voyez ça nuit aux
investissements ça nuit au salaire ça
nuit à la band marche des entreprises et
cetera donc là on est bien dans le sujet
qui défend l'entreprise ben pas ceux qui
se détourne l'argent pour leurs intérêts
personnels voilà donc c'est une drôle de
manière de motiver les cadres dirigeants
des entreprises que de déconnecter leurs
intérêts de ceux de l'entreprise et
c'est bien ce que fait la législ
aujourd'hui donc pour toutes ces raisons
nous pensons que participer au
financement de la retraite par
répartition c'est arrêter de détourner
les de détourner le les salaires en
d'autres types de rémunération et de ce
fait à abaisser le niveau des
cotisations
merci d'autres explications de vote je
n'en vois point ceux qui sont favorbles
B son adoption le manifeste en levant la
main avis
contraire il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'examen du
sous-amendement explication de vote sur
le sousamendement 11 en 99 madame de
moness oui monsieur le
Président je précise que pour que les
choses soient claires que le
sous-amendement numéro
199 a reçu un avis de sagesse de la
commission hein je le précise tout de
suite parce que voilà ça évite les
éventuelles erreurs alors bien
évidemment je précise aussi que c'est C
ce sous-amendement est un
sous-amendement de repli he par rapport
à à tout ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
et tout ce qu'on pense de de
l'amendement
1182 du du
gouvernement il y a dans vos proposition
pour le la possibilité pour les
personnes de bénéficier du taux plein à
65 ans il y a deux
conditions qui nous incitent à faire des
remarques et à poser le problème et à
nous inquiéter la première condition
elle porte le premier élément il porte
justement sur la deuxème condition pour
le maintien du Tau plein à 65 ans et qui
stipule que les personnes doivent avoir
interrompu ou réduit leur activité
professionnel après la naissance ou
l'adoption d'au moins un enfant pour se
consacrer à son éducation je reprends
les terme làin du de l'amendement du
Gouvernement cette condition donc vise à
écarter du dispositif les personne ayant
eu ou élevé un enfant alors qu'elle
n'exerçait pas d'activité profession
or mes collègues l'ont déjà dit ça veut
dire qu'un certain nombre de femmes
particulièrement qui ont fait des
enfants avant d'entrer dans la vie
professionnelle
sont exclus de ce
dispositif ça veut dire aussi en creux
que les personnes qui sont au chômage au
RSA ou sans emploi au moment où elles
ont élevé leurs enfants ne peuvent pas
bénéficier
de ce de cette disposition la le
deuxième problème il porte
sur la trè condition que vous évoquez et
qui est la condition pour les personnes
d'avoir validé avant cette interruption
réduction d'activité un nombre minimum
de
trimestres nous nous posons beaucoup de
questions parce que cette disposition
prévoit donc
que la personne doit déjà avoir
travaillé donc ça on l'a déjà dit mais
on dit aussi
que les
personnes B je le disais tout à l'heure
les personnes qui ont leurs enfants et
ça existe aujourd'hui qui ont eu leurs
enfants entre 18 ans et 20 ans mais ça
existera encore demain là aussi cela
déjà été évoqué est-ce que ces
personneslà seront privées du droit à
retraite à taupelin et enfin la la
question là-dessus sur cette validation
avant interruption d'un nombre minimum
de trimestre c'est combien de trimestres
combien de trimestres vous devez nous
répondre là-dessus on peut pas rester
dans le flou pour pouvoir décider du
vote ou pas du vote de cet amendement
donc je suis solennel en posant ma
question vraiment il faut qu'on ait des
informations sur ce qu'envisage le le
gouvernement sur le nombre minimum de
trimestrees de cotisation avant
l'interruption pour pouvoir bénéficier
du taux plein à 65 ans je vous remercie
de demande d'autres demandes
d'explication de
vote monsieur
Leen et Monsieur
Abou merci Monsieur le présidentjour à
tous en direct sur Public Sénat en
direct de l'hémicycle de la haute
assemblée où vous venez d'entendre
Christiane de moness la sénatrice
socialiste du rô pour batailler
continuer la bataille de l'opposition
contre cette réforme de retraite vous le
savez la semaine qui s'ouvre et pour ce
texte défendu par Eric vert encore
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
une semaine absolument cruciale puisque
en toile de fond de ces débats qui se
poursuivent depuis la semaine dernière
ici au Sénat et bien il y a ces deux
manifestations qui sont évidemment dans
toutes les conversations dans toutes les
discussions ces manifestations dont
l'une est prévue vu demain mardi l'autre
aura lieu vous le savez samedi prochain
le 16 octobre alors toute la semaine
dernière le Sénat a en particulier
développer ses arguments autour de ce
fameux article 5 l'article 5 de du texte
de du gouvernement qui a fait passer
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite de
60 à 62 ans un article 5 qui a été voté
vous vous en souvenez peut-être vendredi
dernier en fin d'après-midi nous en
reviendrons au cours des minutes à su
viivre aujourd'hui dès ce matin dès
lundi et bien la Haute Assemblée a
repris ses débats repris ses discussions
autour du 2e article phare de ce texte
l'article 6 du projet gouvernemental qui
fait passer de 65 à 67 ans l'âge de
départ à la retraite sans décotte alors
dès ce matin dès l'ouverture des débats
le ministre du Travail et Ric vert a
pris la parole et bien j'allais dire
pour cadrer les choses et expliquer
qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir trop
d'exception à au principe au grands
principes aux grands équilibres de cet
article 6 je vous propose de l'entendre
tout de suite le ministre du Travail
Eric vert on peut pas on peut pas à la
fois dire il faut réformer les retraites
et puis en même temps se dire il n'y a
il n'y a que des exceptions à la réforme
des retraites je il faut bien qu'il y
ait un système général qui nous
permettre d'équilibrer notre système de
retraite alors je sais que c'est
difficile et que vous ne voulez pas
écouter c'est propos que au fond il peut
y avoir autant de déficit qu'on veut
c'est pas si grave que ça mais c'est pas
notre position notre position c'est une
position de responsabilité et de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Français
sauver le système des retraites c'est la
première des justices c'est au contraire
ne pas sauver le système de retraite qui
est la première des injustices et qui
paye la première des injustices si le
système de retraite était pas financé
c'est au fond le système de solidarité à
l'intérieur de la retraite il y a 30
milliards d'euros 30 milliards d'euros
qui est au sein de la knnav au travers
du FSV des autres mesures c'est-à-dire
du régime général 30 milliards d'euros
qui finance la solidarité dans le
système de de retraite c'est-à-dire les
les majorations durée d'assurance
c'est-à-dire les congés parentaux
c'est-à-dire le la prise en compte du
chômage c'est 30 milliards d'euros là
c'est-à-dire exactement le niveau du
déficit exactement le niveau du déficit
global de l'ensemble des régimes de de
retraite si nous voulons conserver notre
régime de retraite c'est-à-dire la la
solidarité à l'intérieur de ce ce régime
il faut faire évoluer ce ce système de
retraite et si vous à force d'amendement
ou de sous-amendement vous ne mettez que
des exceptions que des exceptions à la
réforme au fond il y a plus de réforme
il y a plus de réforme si vous
considérez que sur toute la population
féminine il faut pouvoir rester à 65 ans
c'est certainement extrêmement généreux
sauf que ça met en péril le régime de
retraite et quand on met en péril le
régime de retraite on met en péril
l'ensemble des Français et voilà c'était
éc vert le ministre du Travail ce matin
qui recadre les débats et qui pointer du
doigt les différentes exceptions que les
sénateurs en particulier de l'opposition
ont déposé ce matin en particulier pour
vous le savez c'est ce point très
délicat de la retraite des femmes et des
avancées gouvernementales qui avaient eu
lieu dès la semaine dernière dans dans
cet hémicycle Jean-Pierre Bell le
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
va nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
ici en direct de la salle de conférences
mais préalablement je vous propose de
réécouter l'intervention de Jean-Louis
carrer le sénateur socialiste des Landes
il réponter il y a quelques minutes à
peine dans l'hémicycle ici aux propos et
aux arguments défendus par Éric vert le
ministre du Travail Jean-Louis carer
tout de
suite ne me faites pas croire que vous
n'auriez pas compris qu'il y a une forme
d'inéluctabilité à la mobilisation
syndicale que ces pauvres gens qui vont
faire des grèves reconductibles seraient
irresponsable qui ferait courir le
risque au pays après une crise au moment
où ça redémarre de de le bloquer oh là
là oh là là qu'est-ce qui se passe non
c'est vous les responsables c'est vous
pour des raisons idéologiques parce que
le président veut une victoire
idéologique il y a pas d'autre raison
c'est celle-là et si vraiment vous
voulez vous placer sur le terrain de la
démocratie sur le terrain social on peut
ouvrir immédiatement un Grenel de la
retraite dans notre pays qui aurait pour
motive ou pour raison de départ une
négociation sur la durée des cotisations
alors on sait très bien que vous allez
recommencer avec le chiffon rouge et les
socialistes et les socialistes vous
savez à force de parler des socialistes
monsieur le ministre vous nous faites
une pub extraordinaire continuez moi
vous savez à votre place moi moi vous
m'entendez pas souvent parler de votre
mouvement je sais d'ailleurs même pas
comment il s'appelle vous changez
tellement souvent que bon je je je ne me
le rappelle plus mais mais continuez
puis qui croirait dans ce pays monsieur
le ministre
vert que vous détenez la vérité que tout
ce que vous dites est exacte vous croyez
Monsieur le Ministre que lorsque vous
parlez de l'absence de projet alternatif
des socialistes c'est bien ce que vous
faites franchement moi je croyais que
que vous aviez donné une autre image et
que vous pouviez débattre projet contre
projet plutôt que de nier la réalité
c'est quand même pas grandir une
démocratie comme la NRE que de feindre
de d'ignorer le projet alternatif et d'
absolument pas vouloir en discuter avec
les opposants qui représentent Bonan
Malan et puis je vais dire une dernière
chose ce pantomime que vous nous faites
à tous les coups quand vous êtes en
difficulté avec ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler le centre est dramatique
déplorable et moi je pense que notre
démocratie mérite bien mieux donc allons
sur le le terrain de la durée des
cotisations et vous verrez la sérénité
reviendra dans notre pays voilà vous
venez d'entendre un sénateur socialiste
Jean-Louis carer combatif ce matin dans
le l'hémicycle du Sénat à mes côté et
bien le président du groupe socialiste
Jean-Pierre belle merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit ce
matin j'allais dire après une première
semaine de débat aujourd'hui souvre une
deuxième semaine de discussion et de
débats parlementair autour de cette
réforme quel est le l'ambiance au sein
du groupe socialiste que vous idé notre
état d'esprit n'a pas changé depuis la
la semaine dernière nous avons souhaité
qu'il y ait un débat et nous continuons
à à nous y accrocher simplement ce que
nous avons dit aussi ce matin à ce
gouvernement c'est qu'il faut qu'il
qu'il arrête d'une certaine manière des
postures qui le rendent un peu
dogmatique nous nous nous sommes
d'accord arrêtons chacun dans nots
dogmatisme respectif et euh nous avons
constaté quoi ce matin nous avons
constaté nous avons vu un ministre qui
dans le fond mettait en cause j'allais
presque dire le président du Sénat ou en
tout cas beaucoup de membres de la
majorité qui ces jours derniers se sont
exprimés pour dire il n'y a pas de
raison de s'arrêter une catégorie d'âge
extrêmement limité concernant les femmes
ayant élevé trois enfants et encore ce
matin Jean-Pierre Bell on a vu des
amendements des sous-amendements qui
essayaient d'élargir ces possibilités
offertees aux femmes ayant plus de tro
enfants sous amendement de Madame Panis
qui est membre de de l'UMP et qui
s'exprimer aussi au nom de la délégation
des droits aux femmes mais ce qui me
frappe c'est le c'est la fermeture du du
du du du ministre sur tous les sujets
qui sont abordés un peu comme si le
temps parlementaire était réglé par le
temps médiatique le président a dit
alors le président a dit qu'il fallait
passer l'article 5 et l'article 6 avant
le weekend c'est raté puisque l'article
6 n'est pas voté maintenant le président
a dit qu'il faut aller très vite parce
qu'il faut passer un certain nombre de
choses avant la manifestation de demain
donc au pas de charge et on en arrive à
des contradictions assez éclatantes
puisque je vous le dis euh s'agissant
des arguments avancés par Madame Panis
umep ou ou ou monsieur Larcher président
du du du Sénat le le ministre dit
clairement tous ceux qui veulent aller
au-delà de ce que nous nous proposons de
ce que je propose avec le président de
la République sont de dangereux
irresponsables puisque ils ne tiennent
pas compte des impératifs de la réforme
c'est faire bien peu de cas de
personnalité qui essayent de s'exprimer
peut-être avec leur conscience justement
sur ce point Jean-Pierre B je vous
propose d'écouter votre collègue Gérard
Longuet qui préside le groupe UMP ici au
Sénat il était ce matin l'invité deun
confrère d'Europe numéro 1 et pour
Gérard Longuet et bien aujourd'hui et
bien il n'y aurait plus d'avancé
possible sur ce texte de réforme des
retraites on écoute jérard longuer cette
affaire de la décotte vous savez
c'est-à-dire la possibilité de toucher
sa retraite au taux plein sans avoir
cotisé nous allons en effet la rapporter
la reporter de 2 ans pour 201 18 le
législatif c'est nous qui avons la la
responsabilité en votant la loi nous
devons tenir sur l'équilibre global du
système qui a déjà bien amélioré pour le
reste je ne crois pas une paralysie de
notre pays je prends en compte ceux qui
sont en effet inquiets et s'il rentre
dans le débat ils s'apercevront que le
système est raisonnable sur quoi vous
pouvez bouger encore à cet instant je ne
vois pas beaucoup de je ne vois plus de
marge de manœuvre nous avons fait pour
les chômeurs nous l'avons fait pour les
les travailleurs handicapés nous fait
pour les mares de famille nous l'avons
fait pour les parents d'enfants
handicapés ce qui est extrêmement
important je crois que très honnêtement
aujourd'hui on arrive à un système
équilibré après le vote chez vous au
Palais du Luxembourg Gérard Longuet
c'est la commission mixte paritaire
assemblée Sénat qui va approuver ou
voter ex euh nous serons alors à peu
près à quelle date c'est c'est dans la
dernière semaine d'octobre dans le
meilleur des cas voilà dernière semaine
d'octobre selon les Gérard Longuet où
cette réforme des retraites pourrait
être définitive adopté par le Parlement
il y a un sondage très intéressant ce
matin Jean-Pierre belle qui est paru
dans le Parisien Aujourd'hui en France
qui indique grosso modo que les deux
tiers des Français et bien sont contre
cette réforme ils étaient 50 % il y a
encore quelques semaines comment
expliquez-vous cette évolution de
l'opinion sur ce texte oui ce qui est
intéressant c'est c'est que ça ne
faiblit pas et même au contraire ça ça a
l'air de de s'implifier donc moi je je
pense que le débat aura servi on nous
dit de toute façon pourquoi donc il y a
eu débat en particulier ici au Sénat ah
bah encore heureux encore heureux qu'au
Sénat on puisse s'exprimer ouvrir la
bouche et essayer d'avancer quelques
quelques éléments même si vous le voyez
le le le le débat parlementaire lui il
est strictement encadré monsieur longuer
nous dit il n'y a plus aucune marge de
manœuvre sur ce texte on nous explique
que il faut aborder en
priorité le les questions touchant au
départ la ggale de la de la retraite à
60 ans celle concernant le les 65 ans
pourquoi parce que ça rentre dans un
dans un espèce de timing euh qui de
communication qui fait que tout est
réglé un petit peu à l'extérieur voilà
mais euh je pense que si que que les
Français ne sont pas dupes et c'est pour
ça que le sondage dont vous parlez
montre que les 2/ers d'entre eux sont
contre cette réforme c'est quand même
extraordinaires les 2/ers sont contre
presque autant vouloir que la
mobilisation continue ne ne sont pas
opposés aux difficultés qu'il
rencontrent parce que quand il y a des
grèves il y a des difficultés c'est il y
a une vraie détermination de la part des
Français et en face en face il y a quoi
il y a un gouvernement qui anonne qui
répète systématiquement les mêmes choses
qui essaie de faire diversion par des
mesures qui sont extrêmement limitées
qui n'écoutent même pas ses propres
membres bon là je crois que le
gouvernement est est est dans un dans un
moment où il ferait bien peut-être de
prendre un peu de recul par rapport aux
consignes qui ont été passés dans un
petit déjeuner à l'Élysée et peut-être
d'écouter et de remettre à plat un
certain nombre de de d'é parce que si
Monsieur Longuet nous dit alors même que
nous n'avons abordé qu'un article nous
en sommes au deuxième nous dit il y a
plus aucune marge de manœuvre sur un
texte qui en comporte beaucoup ça veut
dire qu'on va parler pour rien vous
pensez que le gouvernement est en train
de perdre la bataille de l'opinion sur
ce texte il il a à mon avis perdu je
crois que c'est c'est important de
constater qu'il n'est pas suivi il n'est
pas suivi parce que cette réforme est
partie d'un mensonge le mensonge c'est
un président de la République qui prend
des engagements devant les Français à
l'occasion de l'élection présidentielle
en disant je ne toucherai pas au départ
âge légal de la retraite et qui fait le
contraire donc à partir de là vous savez
les gens ils sont quand même concerné
par ce sujet dites-moi Jean-Pierre belle
on entend beaucoup le groupe communiste
qui est très virulent très ardent
j'allais dire pour conter cette réformes
des retraites on entend peut-être un peu
moins à la tribune bien qu'on a vu
Jean-Louis carrer tout à l'heure avec
vééence défendre ses opinions est-ce que
vous constatez vous aussi cette espèce
de relative relative timidité de du
groupe socialiste sur ce texte je suis
obligé de de démentir ce que vous venez
de me dire si vous aviez assisté à la
séance ce matin vous auriez vu que les
socialistes euh pour pour ce temps là
euh sont intervenus peut-être beaucoup
plus que tous les tous les autres non je
crois que vous avez tort de dire ça euh
je vous rappelle les grandes
interventions de de de la semaine
dernière je vous rappelle que nous avons
présenté la motion référendaire
simplement pour demander un débat au au
président de la République je vous
rappelle la très belle intervention de
de de de de de pierre monroi je pense
que nous nous avons notre manière de de
nous exprimer dans l'hémicycle mais
regardeer les amendements que nous avons
déposés regarder les interventions nous
ne sommes pas en concurrence avec nos
amis d'autres groupes de gauche et
notamment les les communistes au
contraire nous travaillons ensemble
quelquefois nous nous réunissons
ensemble donc c'est surtout ce qui ce
qui compte c'est de pouvoir montrer
contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement qu'une autre réforme est
possible oui il faut réformer les les
retraites mais le gouvernement ment
lorsqu'il nous dit que seul sa réforme
peut dans le fond avoir une quelconque
crédibilité j'ai passé beaucoup de temps
encore ce matin à expliquer les
différents éléments de la réforme que le
Parti socialiste propose merci merci
beaucoup Jean-Pierre belle d'avoir été
avec nous évidemment le le le débat la
discussion va se poursuivre ici au Sénat
tout au cours de cette semaine avec
antoile Def fond je le disais en
ouverture et bien ces manifestations
prévues demain et samedi c'est la fin de
ce journal des retraite ici au Sénat en
direct sur la chaîne parlementaire tout
de suite la suite de nos programmes
merci à de
12h45
bonjour